It's been four years since I first learned about the disappearance of Neyam May, an 18-year-old who went missing from the small New South Wales town of Batlow back in 2002. I don't know if it's because Neyam and I finished high school in the same year or we shared a similar taste in music, but I felt instinctively drawn to her story. As I learned more about Neyam's story, the revelations that unfolded left me in shock. The result is Missing Neyem, the latest 12-part series from Casefile Presents. Researched and hosted by me, the series features exclusive interviews with key players who help us dive into the details of Neyem's case as we go back to Batlo to try and make sense of
距离我第一次听说内亚姆·梅（Neyam May）失踪的消息已经过去四年了。2002年，这位18岁的女孩在新南威尔士州的小镇巴特洛（Batlow）失踪。我不知道是因为我和内亚姆是同一年高中毕业，还是我们有着相似的音乐品味，但我本能地被她的故事所吸引。随着我对内亚姆故事的深入了解，随之而来的真相让我感到震惊。这就是《Casefile Presents》最新推出的12集系列节目《寻找内亚姆》（Missing Neyem）。该系列由我负责调研和主持，通过对关键人物的独家采访，带我们深入了解内亚姆案件的细节，并重返巴特洛，试图弄清楚
what really happened. The entire 12-part series is available now. Stay tuned to the end of today's episode to hear the trailer. Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. This episode involves crimes against children and won't be suitable for all listeners. Spirits were high for the Balmain Women's Water Polo team on the night of Saturday March 18, 1995. Despite losing against their rival team during the club's grand final a few hours earlier,
到底发生了什么。完整的12集系列节目现已上线。请收听今天节目的结尾，届时将播放预告片。我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您应用中或我们网站上本集的节目说明。本集涉及针对儿童的犯罪，并不适合所有听众。1995年3月18日星期六晚上，巴尔曼女子水球队（Balmain Women's Water Polo team）士气高昂。尽管几个小时前在俱乐部的总决赛中输给了对手，
the players and their supporters were celebrating the end of an otherwise successful season with drinks at a Balmain pub. 19-year-old Kelly Lane was among them, having played a solid game. Her parents had watched the match, but they couldn't stick around for drinks. Instead, Kelly was joined by her boyfriend Duncan Gillies and his mother Julie, who had also attended the game. At around 9pm, a few of Kelly's teammates noticed that Kelly had left without saying a word. Duncan and Julie were still there, so her teammates didn't give it too much thought and continued on with their night.
球员和她们的支持者们还是在巴尔曼的一家酒吧喝酒，庆祝这个虽然有遗憾但依然成功的赛季结束。19岁的凯莉·莱恩（Kelly Lane）也在其中，她在比赛中表现稳健。她的父母观看了比赛，但没能留下来喝酒。相反，凯莉的男友邓肯·吉利斯（Duncan Gillies）和他的母亲朱莉（Julie）也参加了比赛，并陪在凯莉身边。晚上9点左右，凯莉的几名队友注意到凯莉没打招呼就离开了。邓肯和朱莉还在那里，所以队友们没太在意，继续享受她们的夜晚。
Little did any of them know, while playing an impressive grand final in front of a crowd filled with her loved ones, Kelly had been keeping a huge secret. She was nine months pregnant. The reason she'd left the pub was because she'd gone into labour. she'd left the pub, was because she'd gone into labour. Kelly took a taxi alone to the Balmain Hospital about a kilometre away and was subsequently transferred to King George V Memorial Hospital where she gave birth to her first child, Kayla, the following morning. Staff took pity on the polite and warm-natured 19-year-old. Not only was it incredibly rare for a young woman to give birth alone and without a single visitor, in the hours following the
她们谁也没想到，在亲友簇拥下打完一场精彩的总决赛时，凯莉一直隐藏着一个巨大的秘密。她已经怀孕九个月了。她离开酒吧的原因是她开始分娩了。凯莉独自乘出租车前往一公里外的巴尔曼医院，随后被转送到乔治五世国王纪念医院（King George V Memorial Hospital），并于次日清晨生下了她的第一个孩子凯拉（Kayla）。医护人员对这位礼貌且性格温和的19岁女孩产生了怜悯。年轻女性独自生产且没有一个访客的情况极其罕见，而且在分娩后的几个小时里，
delivery it was clear that Kelly was incredibly upset. A social worker was assigned to make sure she was okay. Kelly explained that she and the baby's father, Duncan Gillies, had only recently moved to Sydney from their hometown of Perth, which was why she had no support. Duncan was furthering his rugby career while Kelly was training to play water polo for Australia at the 2000 Olympics. It was the first time that women's water polo would feature at the 2000 Olympics. It was the first time that Women's Water Polo would feature at the event and she hoped to make the team. Unable to care for a child and not wanting to have an abortion, Kelly said the couple had agreed to place Kayla for adoption. On the evening of Tuesday, March 21, 1995, Kelly requested a pass out so she could discuss the
很明显凯莉非常难过。一名社会工作者被指派去确保她的状况。凯莉解释说，她和孩子父亲邓肯·吉利斯刚从家乡珀斯搬到悉尼，这就是她没有亲友支持的原因。邓肯正在发展他的橄榄球事业，而凯莉则在训练，希望能代表澳大利亚参加2000年奥运会。这是女子水球首次被列入奥运会项目，她希望能入选国家队。由于无法照顾孩子，又不想堕胎，凯莉说两人已商定将凯拉送人领养。1995年3月21日星期二晚上，凯莉申请外出，以便私下与
adoption with Duncan in private. Hospital staff granted the request, taking care of baby Kayla so Kelly could get her affairs in order. Kelly returned in the early morning hours, saying Duncan didn't want to be involved in the adoption process. As per protocol, the adoption agency still tried multiple times to contact Duncan using the details Kelly provided. All attempts were unsuccessful. Kelly explained that Duncan was purposely avoiding them because Sheet promised him he didn't need to be involved. Besides, he was about to go overseas to play rugby and would be unreachable for the next two weeks. Eventually, after weeks of trying to contact the Duncan Gillies without success,
邓肯商量领养事宜。医院工作人员批准了请求，并照顾婴儿凯拉，让凯莉去处理事务。凯莉在凌晨时分回来，说邓肯不想参与领养过程。按照程序，领养机构仍多次尝试使用凯莉提供的详细信息联系邓肯，但所有尝试均未成功。凯莉解释说，邓肯是在故意躲避他们，因为她向他保证过他不需要参与。此外，他即将出国打橄榄球，未来两周都无法联系。最终，在尝试联系邓肯·吉利斯数周无果后，
the adoption agency had Kelly sign an affidavit confirming Duncan was Kayla's father and had consented to the adoption. She signed a second affidavit a few weeks later saying Duncan had ended their relationship and wanted nothing to do with their child or the adoption. Just months after giving birth, Kelly went on to represent Australia at a water polo tournament in Canada. Six months later, while Kayla's adoption was still being finalised, Kelly was pregnant again. This time with Tegan. After the 2006 coronial inquest into Teakin Lane's whereabouts, her case was officially handed over to the New South Wales Homicide Squad to be re-investigated from scratch. Detectives reviewed all the evidence
领养机构让凯莉签署了一份宣誓书，确认邓肯是凯拉的父亲并同意领养。几周后，她签署了第二份宣誓书，称邓肯已经结束了他们的关系，不想与他们的孩子或领养事宜有任何瓜葛。生下孩子仅几个月后，凯莉就代表澳大利亚参加了在加拿大举行的水球锦标赛。六个月后，在凯拉的领养手续还在办理时，凯莉又怀孕了。这次怀的是蒂根（Tegan）。在2006年对蒂根·莱恩（Teagan Lane）下落的验尸官调查之后，她的案件被正式移交给新南威尔士州凶杀案调查组，进行从头开始的重新调查。侦探们审查了所有证据，
uncovered so far and undertook their own searches for Teagan Lane and Andrew Norris. They double-checked nationwide records from registry officers, the immigration department, Australia Post, Missing Persons reports and utility companies. Every possible spelling variation of Teagan was considered. Checks were made for any Teagans born in 1996 with a connection to a woman named Mel or any variation of that, such as Melanie or Melissa. or any variation of that, such as Melanie or Melissa. But after two years of intense scrutiny, detectives uncovered nothing. Although Kelly had been caught in countless lies when it came to Teigen's birth, there was one detail in her story that remained unchanged. In each version, she maintained that after being discharged from Auburn Hospital on
并对蒂根·莱恩和安德鲁·诺里斯（Andrew Norris）展开了他们自己的搜寻。他们仔细核对了来自登记处、移民局、澳大利亚邮政、失踪人口报告和公用事业公司的全国记录。他们考虑了蒂根名字的每一种可能的拼写变体。他们还核查了1996年出生的、与名叫梅尔（Mel）或其变体（如梅兰妮或梅丽莎）的女性有联系的任何蒂根。但在经过两年的严密审查后，侦探们一无所获。尽管凯莉在蒂根出生的问题上撒了无数谎，但她故事中有一个细节始终未变。在每个版本中，她都坚持说在从奥本医院（Auburn Hospital）出院后，
Saturday September 14 1996, she went back to Duncan Gilley's house in Gladesville. Although detectives conducted a cursory search of the property during the missing person investigation in 2003, the homicide squad decided it was worth taking a closer look. 2003, the Homicide Squad decided it was worth taking a closer look. In early August 2008, Duncan's former property was cordoned off as an extensive search commenced. The Weather Board home had undergone significant renovations a couple of years prior, yet police remained hopeful they might uncover something of interest. Over five days, they scoured the property with cadaver dogs, checking the yard, the roof, and inside the walls, while a forensic anthropologist sifted through the soil underneath the house. They identified several small bone fragments which were sent away for
1996年9月14日星期六，她回到了位于格莱兹维尔（Gladesville）的邓肯·吉利斯的家。尽管侦探在2003年的失踪人口调查期间对该房产进行了粗略搜查，但凶杀案调查组认为有必要进行更仔细的检查。2008年8月初，邓肯的前房产被封锁，大规模搜查随即展开。这座木板房几年前曾进行过重大翻修，但警方仍希望能发现一些有价值的线索。在五天的时间里，他们带着搜尸犬搜查了房产，检查了院子、屋顶和墙壁内部，同时一名法医人类学家在房屋下方的土壤中进行筛查。他们发现了几个小骨头碎片，并被送去进行
further testing. Results concluded that they weren't human. By this point, Teagan Lane's case had been in the hands of police for more than eight and a half years, and in the public spotlight for three. In all that time, investigators failed to uncover a single piece of evidence indicating what had happened to Teigen. Police had been keeping a close eye on Kelly with another covert tap placed on her phone. 1200 phone calls were recorded in 2008 in addition to the 700 intercepted in 2004. While Kelly said nothing incriminating during any of these calls, there was something about them that investigators found significant. At no point did Kelly Lane make her own attempts
进一步检测。结果显示它们不是人类的。此时，蒂根·莱恩的案件已经在警方手中超过八年半，并处于公众聚光灯下三年了。在这段时间里，调查人员未能发现任何能表明蒂根遭遇的证据。警方一直密切监视凯莉，并在她的电话上安装了另一个秘密窃听器。除了2004年拦截的700个电话外，2008年又录制了1200个电话。虽然凯莉在这些通话中没有说任何有罪的话，但调查人员发现其中有些内容意义重大。凯莉·莱恩从未尝试过
to find her missing daughter. It was something they denoted early in the investigation. If Kelly's story about giving Tegan to Andrew Norris was true, and she'd so desperately wanted to keep the whole ordeal a secret from her family and friends, then why hadn't she tried to find the pair herself? Kelly initially claimed to have old diaries that might have outdated contact details for Andrew and some mutual friends, yet she never attempted to track these down. One journalist discovered that in 2003, Kelly visited a website that aimed to reconnect long-lost school friends. She posted a brief message which read, Looking for Andrew Norris, aged approx 38, went to school, possibly Western Sydney,
寻找她失踪的女儿。这是他们在调查初期就注意到的事情。如果凯莉关于把蒂根交给安德鲁·诺里斯的故事是真的，而且她如此迫切地想对家人和朋友隐瞒整个过程，那么为什么她自己不去寻找这对父女呢？凯莉最初声称有旧日记，里面可能有安德鲁和一些共同朋友的过时联系方式，但她从未尝试去寻找这些线索。一位记者发现，2003年，凯莉访问了一个旨在重新联系失散多年的校友的网站。她发布了一条简短的信息，写道：寻找安德鲁·诺里斯，大约38岁，上过学，可能在西悉尼，
went on to university, then entered stockbroking slash money markets. She shared a similar message shortly after, adding that the Andrew Norris she was looking for had a partner named Melanie and they might now be married. No one responded and Kelly didn't appear to make any attempts beyond that. While this wasn't an indicator of guilt, it led some to believe that Kelly wasn't trying to track Teagan down because she already knew Teagan was dead. But like everything else in the case, this was just an unsubstantiated theory. After two years of investigations, the homicide squad still had no concrete evidence tying Kelly to Teagan's death, but they remained convinced she had killed the
后来上了大学，然后进入了股票经纪或货币市场行业。不久后，她分享了类似的信息，补充说她正在寻找的安德鲁·诺里斯有一个名叫梅兰妮的伴侣，他们现在可能已经结婚了。没有人回应，凯莉似乎也没有再做任何尝试。虽然这并不是有罪的指标，但这让一些人认为，凯莉没有试图寻找蒂根，是因为她已经知道蒂根死了。但就像案件中的其他一切一样，这只是一个未经证实的理论。经过两年的调查，凶杀案调查组仍然没有确凿的证据将凯莉与蒂根的死亡联系起来，但他们仍然确信她杀害了
newborn. The fact of the matter was, there was nothing to suggest anyone had ever seen Teagan Lane after she and Kelly were discharged from Auburn Hospital at around midday on Saturday September 14 1996. By 3pm, Kelly was at her parents' house in Fairlight with no baby in sight. If it took around an hour to make the drive, then what was Kelly doing during the unaccounted for two-hour window? Based on the evidence at hand, investigators started to piece together what they believed to be a likely scenario. By the time 21-year-old Kelly was nearing the end of her pregnancy with Teigen, she was no longer the naive first-time mother she'd been when Kayla was born almost 18 months earlier. As she'd learned from her experience at the Balmain Pub, labour could occur at any time.
这个新生儿。事实是，没有任何迹象表明在1996年9月14日星期六中午左右，凯莉和蒂根从奥本医院出院后，有人见过蒂根·莱恩。下午3点，凯莉出现在她位于费尔莱特（Fairlight）的父母家中，身边没有婴儿。如果开车需要大约一个小时，那么凯莉在那两个小时的空窗期里在做什么？根据现有的证据，调查人员开始拼凑出他们认为可能发生的情况。当21岁的凯莉怀蒂根接近尾声时，她已不再是18个月前生下凯拉时那个天真的新手妈妈了。正如她从巴尔曼酒吧的经历中所学到的，分娩随时可能发生。
Knowing she was expected to attend the wedding of Duncan's family friends on Saturday September 14 1996, she couldn't risk going into labour in front of the other guests or at any other awkward moment. Time was of the essence. In early September, Duncan was out of town on a rugby trip, giving Kelly an ample window of opportunity to give birth without those close to her finding out. Medical records showed she visited Wright Hospital on Saturday September 7, Monday September 9, and then again on Tuesday September 10. Each time she claimed her baby was overdue, which had derailed her plan of a home birth with her private midwife. And each time she sought to have an induction. Without any antenatal records to prove the baby's gestation, hospital staff denied each of her requests. On Wednesday, September 11, 1996, Kelly went to Auburn Hospital on the other side of town,
由于知道她必须参加1996年9月14日星期六邓肯家朋友的婚礼，她不能冒着在其他客人面前或在任何尴尬时刻分娩的风险。时间紧迫。9月初，邓肯去外地参加橄榄球比赛，这给了凯莉一个充足的机会，可以在不被亲近的人发现的情况下生下孩子。医疗记录显示，她分别在9月7日星期六、9月9日星期一和9月10日星期二访问了赖特医院（Wright Hospital）。每次她都声称孩子过期妊娠，这打乱了她在家中由私人助产士接生的计划。而且每次她都要求引产。由于没有任何产前记录来证明胎龄，医院工作人员拒绝了她的每一个请求。1996年9月11日星期三，凯莉去了城另一头的奥本医院，
giving the same story she'd given at Ryde. There, her request to be induced was granted. Her request to be induced was granted. Teigen was born on Thursday September 12. Investigators believed it was at this point that Kelly started to panic. The unexpected complications with her retained placenta meant she required post-op care, and she'd be pushing it to be discharged in time to attend the wedding on Saturday. and she'd be pushing it to be discharged in time to attend the wedding on Saturday. Knowing she couldn't take Teigen home, but unwilling to go through what she now knew to be a lengthy, complicated and emotionally gruelling adoption process, Kelly lied to hospital staff and said she'd be receiving at-home care from her private midwife. On Saturday September 14, she was granted permission to leave as long as she completed some paperwork, including the Guthrie Test consent form and the registration
讲述了她在赖德医院讲过的同样的故事。在那里，她的引产请求得到了批准。蒂根于9月12日星期四出生。调查人员认为，就在这时，凯莉开始恐慌了。胎盘残留带来的意外并发症意味着她需要术后护理，而她要在周六及时出院去参加婚礼将非常勉强。由于知道不能带蒂根回家，又不愿经历她现在所知的漫长、复杂且令人精疲力竭的领养过程，凯莉对医院工作人员撒谎，说她将由私人助产士进行居家护理。9月14日星期六，在完成了一些文书工作后，她获准离开，其中包括Guthrie测试同意书和提交给出生、死亡和婚姻登记处的登记
form to submit to the Registry of Births, Deaths and Marriages. An appointment was also made for a midwife to visit her at home in a few days' time. With just hours to spare before the wedding, Kelly left at around midday without completing any of the paperwork or signing the discharge papers. No hospital staff or the other patient Kelly was sharing a room with recalled seeing Kelly and Teagan leave that day. However, there was an unalarmed fire escape directly opposite their room which Kelly could have exited from without passing the nurses station. There was no CCTV footage to prove what happened after Kelly left the hospital, but she claimed that was when she met up with Andrew Norris, Andrew's mother,
表格。医院还预约了助产士在几天后去她家探访。在距离婚礼仅剩几个小时的时候，凯莉在中午左右离开，没有完成任何文书工作，也没有签署出院文件。没有医院工作人员或与凯莉同住一室的另一位病人记得那天看到凯莉和蒂根离开。然而，她们房间正对面有一个没有警报的消防通道，凯莉可以从那里离开而不经过护士站。没有闭路电视录像证明凯莉离开医院后发生了什么，但她声称那时她与安德鲁·诺里斯、安德鲁的母亲以及他的伴侣梅尔见了面，并将蒂根交给了他们。凯莉最初声称是乘出租车回家的，但后来又说她是自己开的车。凶杀案侦探核查了悉尼的每一家出租车公司，发现没有1996年9月14日星期六从奥本医院接载任何乘客的记录。因此，他们认为凯莉是自己开车回家的，并在旅途中的某个时刻杀害了她两天的婴儿并处理了尸体。然后她像什么都没发生一样继续生活，那天晚上参加了婚礼，在那里她被看到在社交、喝酒和跳舞。9月16日星期一，凯莉打电话给助产士项目并取消了他们为她预约的探访，
and his partner Mel, to hand Teagan over. Kelly initially claimed to have taken a taxi home, but later said she'd driven herself. Homicide detectives ran checks with every taxi company in Sydney and found no records of any passengers being picked up from Auburn Hospital on Saturday, September 14, 1996. They therefore believed that Kelly had driven herself home, and at some point during that journey, she killed her two-day-old baby and disposed of her body. She then went about life as though nothing had happened, attending the wedding that evening where she was observed socialising, drinking and dancing. On Monday September 16, Kelly called the midwife program and cancelled the appointment they'd
说她的私人助产士已经处理好了一切。在接下来的几天和几周里，没有任何迹象表明凯莉患有产后抑郁症或任何其他精神障碍。因此，调查人员认为蒂根的谋杀案是出于凯莉希望在不被任何人发现她生过孩子的情况下继续生活的愿望。摆脱蒂根不仅可以掩盖她的不忠并消除为人父母的责任，还能使她能够追求在2000年悉尼奥运会上打水球的梦想。1997年底，凯莉询问澳大利亚体育学院是否可以推迟她的高等
made for her, saying her private midwife had everything under control. In the following days and weeks, there was nothing to suggest Kelly was suffering from postnatal depression or any other mental disturbance. Therefore, investigators believed Teagan's murder was motivated by Kelly's desire to move on without anyone discovering she'd given birth. Getting rid of Teagan would not only conceal her infidelity and remove the responsibility of parenthood, it would enable her to pursue her dream of playing water polo in the upcoming Sydney 2000 Olympics. In late 1997, Kelly asked the Australian College of Physical Education if she could defer her tertiary
学业，以专注于入选澳大利亚奥运代表队。三年来，她成功地过着蒂根从未存在过的生活，而她身边的人也一无所知。直到1999年通过婴儿雅各布（Jacob）的领养事件曝光了蒂根的出生，凯莉的罪行才因她众多的谎言而变得显而易见。她不仅对医院工作人员、领养机构、社会工作者和警察说了八个不同的故事，还有其他不一致之处也引起了怀疑。即，为什么凯莉最初说她无法找到安德鲁·诺里斯的公寓，后来当警察开车带她经过他所在的社区时，她却能轻松找到？为什么她告诉侦探她去邓肯的老房子寻找安德鲁的电话号码，而实际上她并没有去？凯莉还说她的朋友圈自1996年以来已经改变，她不再认识那时的人，而实际上她一直保持着从童年及以后开始的亲密友谊。她在蒂根父亲的说法上也存在漏洞。如果凯莉真的安排安德鲁带走蒂根，那么为什么用她自己的医疗保险卡登记，而不是用他的？
studies to concentrate on making the Australian Olympic team. For three years she successfully lived her life as though Teagan had never existed, and those close to her were none the wiser. It was only when Teagan's birth was exposed through the adoption of baby Jacob in 1999 that Kelly's guilt became obvious due to her multitude of lies. Not only had she told eight different stories to hospital staff, adoption agencies, social workers and police, there were other inconsistencies that also raised suspicion. Namely, why had Kelly initially said she wouldn't
如果安德鲁愿意抚养蒂根，为什么他不去做一件像在登记处登记出生这样简单的事情？在调查人员看来，这些不一致之处的唯一解释是，医院工作人员曾敦促凯莉填写医疗保险表格，而她找不到绕过它的方法。安德鲁从未登记蒂根的出生或申请单独的医疗保险卡，因为安德鲁根本就不存在。凶杀案调查组的问题在于，无论他们对这种情况有多么确信，他们都没有实物证据来证明这一点。他们向
be able to find Andrew Norris' apartment, then located it with ease when police drove her through his neighbourhood? Why did she tell detectives she'd gone to Duncan's old house to search for Andrew's phone number when she hadn't? Kelly also said her circle of friends had changed since 1996 and she no longer knew people from back then, when in reality she'd maintained close friendships from childhood and beyond. There were holes in her claims about Teigen's father too. If Kelly really did arrange for Andrew to take Teegan, then why register her on her own Medicare card rather than his?
公诉主任提交了案件，后者在调查继续的同时审查了该案12个月。在此期间，没有出现蒂根或安德鲁的任何迹象，这增加了蒂根已死且安德鲁是凯莉虚构人物的理论的分量。2009年11月，公诉主任做出了决定。凯莉·莱恩被控谋杀蒂根。虽然检方认为他们有强有力的证据，但他们完全意识到仅凭间接证据上法庭所面临的挑战。没有蒂根的尸体，他们甚至无法确定是否发生了谋杀。即使陪审团相信凯莉在把蒂根交给亲生父亲这件事上撒了谎，这仍然不能证明她对孩子造成了伤害，或者孩子已经死亡。
And if Andrew was willing to raise Tegan, why didn't he do something as simple as register her birth with the registry office? As far as investigators were concerned, the only explanation for these inconsistencies was that the hospital staff had urged Kelly to fill out the Medicare form and she couldn't see a way around it. Andrew never registered Teagan's birth or sought a separate Medicare card, because Andrew never existed in the first place. The problem for the homicide squad was that it didn't matter how convinced they were of this scenario, they had no physical evidence to prove it. They presented
虽然凯莉秘密怀孕、领养和撒谎的历史确实令人信服，但从法律角度来看，这些细节与蒂根的案件没有关联，因此很可能被认为在法庭上不可采信。然而，当凯莉的其他孩子凯拉和雅各布出生并被领养时，凯莉签署的宣誓书中包含了各种虚假陈述，包括邓肯·吉利斯是两个婴儿的父亲。在雅各布的案件中，凯莉后来签署了另一份宣誓书，声称父亲实际上是一个名叫亚伦·威廉姆斯（Aaron Williams）的男人，她在伦敦认识了他。作为凶杀案调查的一部分进行的DNA测试证实，邓肯不是这两个孩子的父亲，而亚伦·威廉姆斯被认为是凯莉想象出来的产物。
their case to the director of public prosecutions who reviewed the case for 12 months while the investigation continued. During that time, no sign of Teagan or Andrew surfaced, adding weight to the theory that Teagan was dead and Andrew was a fictional character created by Kelly. In November 2009, the DPP made their decision. Kelly Lane was charged with Teagan's murder. While the prosecution felt they had a strong case, they were fully aware of the challenges they faced by going to court with only circumstantial evidence. Without Teagan's body, they couldn't be certain that a murder had even occurred. Even if the jury believed Kelly was lying about giving Teigen to her biological father, it still didn't prove that she'd done anything to harm the child, or that the child was even dead.
其他虚假陈述涉及凯莉提供的地址以及父亲对领养的知情情况。但谎言并没有就此停止。事实证明，当凯莉在凯拉出生后向医院申请外出时，她并不是像她告诉工作人员的那样去见凯拉的父亲。那天是凯莉的20岁生日。她是出去和朋友庆祝了。基于这些宣誓书上的谎言，公诉主任决定以三项伪证罪起诉凯莉，并与谋杀罪同时审理。这在法律界被视为极其高明的一招。这不仅意味着检方可以通过利用凯莉的
While Kelly's history of secret pregnancies, adoptions and lies was certainly compelling. From a legal standpoint, these details had no relevance to Teagan's case and would therefore likely be deemed inadmissible in court. However, when Kelly's other children, Kayla and Jacob, were born and adopted, Kelly had signed affidavits that featured various false statements, including that Duncan Gillies was the father of both babies. In Jacob's case, Kelly later signed another affidavit claiming the father was really a man named Aaron Williams whom she'd met in London. DNA tests conducted as part of the homicide investigation confirmed that Duncan wasn't the father of either child, while Aaron Williams was deemed to be a product of Kelly's imagination.
秘密怀孕和领养历史来加强他们的案件，还会在陪审团面前削弱她的可信度。但选择一个公正的陪审团本身就是一个挑战。当萨曼莎·克拉克（Samantha Clark，化名）听说对蒂根·莱恩的调查时，她认出了凯莉·莱恩。萨曼莎在昆士兰州的一家专门从事晚期堕胎的诊所工作。1999年2月，凯莉联系了该诊所，寻求终止她声称的怀有雅各布的24周妊娠。诊所进行终止手术的最晚期限是25周。随着时间流逝，凯莉独自前往布里斯班进行手术。
The other false statements related to addresses Kelly had given and the father's knowledge of the adoptions. But the lies didn't stop there. of the adoptions. But the lies didn't stop there. It turned out that when Kelly requested a pass out from the hospital after Kayla's birth, she wasn't going to speak to Kayla's father as she told the staff. That day had been Kelly's 20th birthday. She had gone out to celebrate with friends. She had gone out to celebrate with Franz. Based on the lies on these sworn affidavits, the DPP made the decision to charge Kelly with three counts of perjury to be tried at the same time as the murder charge. This was viewed in legal circles as an incredibly clever move. Not only did it mean the prosecution could strengthen their case by using Kelly's
当她到达诊所时，检查显示她已经超过了截止日期，怀孕约六个半月。因此，医生无法进行手术，凯莉回到了悉尼，并在两个半月后生下了雅各布。在新闻中看到蒂根的案件后，萨曼莎记起了凯莉的来访，并打电话给凶杀案调查组报告了此事。毕竟，调查提出的一个响亮的问题是，为什么凯莉费尽心思隐瞒怀孕而不是选择终止妊娠。凯莉的母亲桑德拉（Sandra）在调查中作证说，她并不特别赞成堕胎，并说凯莉可能知道她的观点。
history of secret pregnancies and adoptions, it would also cast doubt on her credibility before a jury. But selecting an unbiased jury was proving to be a challenge in and of itself. 12. When Samantha Clark, not her real name, heard about the investigation into Teagan Lane, she recognised Kelly Lane. Samantha worked at a clinic in Queensland that specialised in late-term abortions. In February 1999, Kelly contacted the clinic seeking determination of what she claimed to be her 24-week pregnancy with Jacob. The latest the clinic would perform a termination was 25 weeks. With the clock ticking, Kelly travelled to Brisbane alone to have the procedure.
凯莉的父亲罗伯特（Robert）作证说，他曾问凯莉为什么不终止妊娠，她说了一些类似“我不能伤害婴儿”的话。但事实是，凯莉1999年去昆士兰实际上是她第三次进入堕胎诊所。在调查过程中，发现凯拉并不是凯莉的第一次怀孕。她在17岁时第一次怀孕。那是1992年，父亲是她的第一个男友，一名叫亚伦·泰亚克（Aaron Tyak）的冲浪救生员。凯莉告诉了亚伦怀孕的事，但对其他人保密。两人最终决定终止妊娠。凯莉选择独自去预约，当她之后与
When she arrived at the clinic, an examination revealed she was already beyond the cutoff point at around six and a half months pregnant. The doctor was therefore unable to proceed, and Kelly returned to Sydney, where she gave birth to Jacob two and a half months later. After seeing Tegan's case on the news, Samantha remembered Kelly's visit and called the homicide squad to report it. After all, one of the resounding questions raised by the inquest was why Kelly had gone to such great lengths to conceal her pregnancies instead of having them terminated. Kelly's mother Sandra had testified at the inquest that she didn't particularly believe in abortion and said it was possible that Kelly knew of her view.
亚伦见面时，她崩溃了。他向澳大利亚广播公司（ABC）描述她是一个“破碎的女孩”。亚伦不知道的是，凯莉在第二年，即1993年11月，在他们的关系即将结束时又怀孕了。这次她没有告诉任何人。她在怀孕五个月时独自去了一家诊所并进行了堕胎。凯莉在17岁到24岁之间怀孕了五次，尽管她一直在服用避孕药，而且没有一个朋友或家人知道这件事。检方知道，凯莉终止妊娠和将婴儿送人领养的历史会引起一些潜在陪审团成员的强烈反应。他们必须格外小心，以确保凯莉是因为蒂根的
Kelly's father, Robert, testified that he'd asked Kelly why she didn't terminate the pregnancies and she said something along the lines of, I couldn't hurt a baby. But the truth was, Kelly's visit to Queensland in 1999 was actually the third time she'd been inside an abortion clinic. Through the course of the investigation, it was revealed that Kayla wasn't Kelly's first pregnancy. She became pregnant for the first time at age 17. It was 1992 and the father was her first boyfriend, a surf lifesaver named Aaron Tyak. Kelly told Aaron about the pregnancy but kept it a secret from everyone else. The couple ultimately decided to terminate the pregnancy. Kelly chose to go to the appointment alone and when she met
谋杀案而受审，而不是因为她的性取向或她被认为的道德标准。Casefile稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集的赞助商来支持我们。有了Robin Hood Gold，您不需要含着金汤匙就能享受到1%人群的财务优惠。Robin Hood Gold允许其他人获得通常留给上流社会的利率和福利。现在，拥有Robinhood Gold的足智多谋的个人可以在未投资的现金上赚取4.5% APY的非常慷慨的利率，获得无限的1%存款奖金，并因IRA账户上的3%退休金提升而获得奖励。Robinhood Gold为任何净资产的人提供高净值人士的特权。
up with Aaron afterwards, she was devastated. He described her to the ABC as being a shattered girl. What Aaron didn't know was that Kelly became pregnant again the following year in November 1993 as their relationship was coming to an end. This time she didn't tell anybody. She went to a clinic by herself at five months pregnant and had an abortion. Kelly had been pregnant five times between the ages of 17 and 24, despite being on the contraceptive pill, and not a single friend or family member ever knew about it. Prosecutors knew that Kelly's history of terminating pregnancies and placing babies for adoption would elicit a strong response from some prospective jury members. They'd have to take extra caution to ensure that Kelly was being tried for Teigen's
这些慷慨的福利现在每月仅需5美元。新的黄金标准随着Robinhood Gold而来。请在robinhood.com gold注册。条款适用于产品特定披露，请访问robinhood.com gold。投资涉及风险，利率可能会变动。黄金会员资格由Robinhood Gold LLC提供。世界在不断发展，从机器人吸尘器到智能冰箱，一切都在改善我们的生活和工作方式。随着技术的进步，您的业务也应该跟上步伐。
murder and not for her sexuality or her perceived morals. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. With Robin Hood Gold, you don't need a silver spoon to eat up the financial favours of the 1%. Robin Hood Gold allows others to get the rates and perks usually reserved for the high society. Now, the resourceful individual with Robinhood Gold can earn the very liberal rate of 4.5% APY on uninvested cash, receive unlimited 1% deposit bonuses, and be rewarded with a handsome 3% retirement boost on an IRA account. Robinhood Gold provides the privileges of a high net worth for any net worth.
无论您是在成长，还是旧的运输解决方案不再适用，ShipStation都能为您提供帮助。ShipStation在电子商务平台、市场和承运商之间拥有超过180种集成，确保您的业务与您使用的设备一样智能。Casefile团队成员宝琳娜（Paulina）为她的Shopify商店注册了ShipStation，并对自动化运输任务的简便性感到震惊。通过在一个简单的仪表板中管理一切，宝琳娜只需点击一下即可跟踪订单并打印运输标签。如果您想将您的电子商务业务提升到一个新的水平，ShipStation是您需要的工具。这是以高达89%的UPS、DHL Express和USPS费率折扣向客户运送产品的最快、最实惠的方式。此外，您可以与您已经使用的服务和销售
These generous benefits are now available for only $5 per month. The new gold standard is here with Robinhood Gold. Sign up at robinhood.com gold. Terms apply for product specific disclosures visit robinhood.com gold. Investing involves risk, rate may change. Gold membership is offered by Robinhood Gold LLC. The world is constantly evolving with everything from robot vacuums to smart refrigerators improving how we live and work. As technology advances, your business should keep up too.
渠道无缝集成，使在一个地方管理一切变得比以往任何时候都更容易。用能够交付的运输软件引领您的电子商务业务走向更智能的未来。今天就切换到ShipStation。前往ShipStation.com并使用代码CASEFILE注册您的免费60天试用。这就是ShipStation.com代码CASEFILE。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供高质量的内容。凯莉·莱恩被控谋杀蒂根的消息将案件重新推向了头条新闻，谣言工厂全速运转。随着凯莉私生活的曝光，公众对她
Whether you're growing or your old shipping solutions no longer cut it, ShipStation is here to help. With over 180 integrations across e-commerce platforms, marketplaces and carriers, ShipStation ensures your business is as smart as the devices you use. Casefile team member Paulina signed up to ShipStation for her Shopify store and was blown away by how easy it was to automate shipping tasks. With everything managed in one simple dashboard, Paulina can track orders and print shipping labels with just a click. If you're looking to take your e-commerce business to the next level, ShipStation is the tool you need. It's the fastest, most affordable way to ship products to your customers with discounts up to 89% off UPS, DHL Express and USPS rates. Plus, you can seamlessly integrate with the services and selling
一系列怀孕事件有了自己耸人听闻的问题。凯拉和雅各布的DNA测试结果尚未公开，导致一些人怀疑凯莉是否在父亲身份上撒谎，以掩盖她受到性虐待的事实。有传言说她可能是被施虐者弄怀孕的，并因为对自己深陷否认之中而对怀孕保密。其他人则对凯莉被认为的滥交行为议论纷纷，一些人猜测她的孩子都是随机、匿名性接触的结果。警方从凯莉在1990年代已知有性关系的男人那里获得了DNA。事实证明，凯拉的
channels you already use, making it easier than ever to manage everything in one place. Lead your e-commerce business into a smarter future with the shipping software that delivers. Switch to ShipStation today. Go to ShipStation.com and use code CASEFILE to sign up for your free 60-day trial. That's ShipStation.com code CASEFILE. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. The news that Kelly Lane had been charged with Teegans murder propelled the case back into the headlines, with the rumour mill swinging into overdrive. With Kelly's private life exposed, the public had their own salacious questions about her
父亲是她在开始与邓肯约会时一直在交往的一名橄榄球运动员。雅各布的父亲是她兄弟的朋友，她在与邓肯的关系结束后曾与他随意约会。这两个男人都不知道凯莉怀孕了，得知自己是她孩子的父亲时感到非常震惊。虽然他们的身份为了保护凯拉和雅各布的隐私而未向公众公开，但消息在曼利（Manly）社区传开了。凯莉的密友开始疏远她，无法理解
string of pregnancies. The results of Kayla and Jacob's DNA tests hadn't yet been made public, leading some to wonder if Kelly had lied about their paternity to cover up the fact that she was being sexually abused. There were whispers that she might have been impregnated by her tormentor and had kept the pregnancy secret because she was so deeply in denial about them herself. Others gossiped about Kelly's perceived promiscuity, with some speculating that her children were all the result of random, anonymous sexual encounters. Police obtained DNA from the man Kelly was known to have had sexual relations with during the 1990s. It turned out that Kayla's
这些年来她对他们隐瞒了多少。谣言造成了损失，到凯莉被控谋杀蒂根时，她的生活看起来与调查时截然不同。她失去了在雷文斯伍德女子学校（Ravenswood School for Girls）心爱的工作，在一家物理治疗师办公室担任接待员。她的婚姻已经破裂并以离婚告终。但有一件事保持不变。凯莉坚定地坚持自己是无辜的。在凯莉的辩护团队看来，他们的客户被定罪的可能性相对较小。毕竟，
father was a rugby player she'd been seeing around the time she started dating Duncan. Jacob's father was a friend of her brother's whom she'd dated casually after her relationship with Duncan ended. Neither of the men had any idea that Kelly had been pregnant and were completely shocked to learn that they had fathered her children. While their identities were withheld from the public to protect Kayla and Jacob's privacy, completely shocked to learn that they had fathered her children. While their identities were withheld from the public to protect Kayla and Jacob's privacy, word got out amongst the manly community. Close friends of Kelly started to distance themselves from her, unable to comprehend
没有任何确凿的证据表明蒂根已经死亡，更不用说她是如何死亡的，或者凯莉伤害了她。凯莉绝对没有暴力史，并且有40多位了解她的人提供的品格证明，所有人都证明她永远不会伤害孩子。据各方说法，凯莉是一位出色的母亲和老师，与年幼的孩子有特殊的亲和力。许多人谈到了她与女儿艾米丽（Emily）之间深厚的爱。他们称赞凯莉在被媒体诋毁、私生活细节被大肆报道时的力量和勇气。如果有的话，辩方认为凯莉将她的另外两个孩子送人领养
just how much she had kept from them over the years. The rumours took their toll, and by the time Kelly was charged with Teigen's murder, her life looked markedly different than it did at the time of the inquest. She'd lost the job she loved at Ravenswood School for Girls and was working as a receptionist at a physiotherapist office. Her marriage had disintegrated and ended in divorce. But there was one thing that remained unchanged. Kelly's staunch insistence that she was innocent. As far as Kelly's defence team was concerned, the chances of their client being convicted were relatively slim. After all,
证明她是一个负责任的年轻女性。她两次完成了这个过程，尽管情感上的代价表明她有多么关心她婴儿的福祉。将蒂根交给她的亲生父亲只是另一种善举。是的，凯莉撒了很多谎，浪费了像领养代理人弗吉尼亚·冯（Virginia Fung）这样的人的努力，但这并不使她成为杀人犯。在她秘密怀孕时，她只是一个没有成熟度或经验来处理困难和情感事件的年轻人，尤其是在没有亲人支持的情况下。凯莉的辩护团队还认为，调查人员未能建立一个令人信服的动机。
there wasn't any concrete evidence that Teagan was dead, let alone how she died or that Kelly had harmed her. Kelly had absolutely no history of violence and had character references from more than 40 people who knew her well, all attesting she would never hurt a child. By all accounts, Kelly was a wonderful mother and teacher who had a special rapport with young children. Many spoke of the deep loving bond she shared with her daughter, Emily. They commended Kelly's strength and courage as she was vilified by the media and the details of her private life were splashed across the news. If anything, the defence believed that Kelly placing her other two children for adoption
关于凯莉的奥运抱负以及她不惜一切代价入选国家队的愿望，有很多讨论。在辩方看来，凯莉甚至从未成为奥运代表队的有力竞争者。凯莉的朋友或前教练中没有人记得她曾谈论过想参加奥运会，而且教练认为她无论如何都没有入选国家队的实力。即使那是她的目标，而安德鲁无法带走孩子，那么假设她会像对待凯拉和雅各布一样继续领养也是合理的。凯莉的律师还嘲笑了凯莉为了参加当天晚上的婚礼而杀害蒂根的说法。凯莉几乎不认识要结婚的那对夫妇。她只是作为邓肯·吉利斯的客人出席，而他与他们也不是特别亲近。
proved she was a responsible young woman. She'd gone through with the process twice, despite the emotional toll which showed how much she cared about the wellbeing of her babies. Handing Tegan over to her biological father was just another act of kindness. Yes, Kelly had told many lies and wasted the efforts of people like adoption agent Virginia Fung, but that didn't make her a murderer. At the time of her secret pregnancies, she was simply a young person who didn't have the maturity or experience to deal with the difficult and emotional events, especially without support from her loved ones. Kelly's defence team also believed that investigators had failed to establish a convincing motive.
如果凯莉真的想参加婚礼，那么为什么她不申请医院的夜间外出许可，把蒂根留在工作人员的照顾下，就像她前一年凯拉出生时所做的那样？在凯莉的辩护团队看来，她不是那种会想到谋杀婴儿的人，更不用说去实施了。除了动机问题，还有一个问题是凯莉是否患有任何可能导致她行为的精神疾病。在对蒂根下落的调查过程中，凯莉拒绝参加咨询或接受心理评估。她最接近的一次是在2004年的验尸官调查期间，当时她的父母叫了一名全科医生到他们家，因为凯莉处于
There had been lots of talk about Kelly's Olympic ambitions and her desire to make the team at any cost. As far as the defence was concerned, Kelly had never even been a serious contender for the Olympic team. None of Kelly's friends or former coaches record her ever speaking about wanting to compete at the Olympics, and the coach didn't think she had what it took to make the team anyway. Even if that had been her goal and Andrew wasn't able to take the baby, then it made sense to assume she would have proceeded with adoption, just as she had with Kayla and Jacob. Kelly's lawyers also scoffed at the suggestion that Kelly was motivated to kill Teigen so she could attend the wedding later that day. Kelly barely knew the couple who were getting married. She was only there as Duncan Gilley' guest and he wasn't particularly close to them either.
痛苦状态。凯莉告诉医生她感到困惑和害怕，不知道如何处理她所处的境地。她后悔没有告诉父母怀孕的事，但她在体育事业方面承受了很大的期望。凯莉说她被这些期望所困，而内心深处她并不快乐，想要与生活不同的东西。全科医生认为凯莉的怀孕是一种对爱的呼唤。他认为，怀孕不是谈论她的感受，而是一种试图管理这种情况的功能失调的方式。医生陈述道，
And if Kelly really did want to attend the wedding, then why wouldn't she just request a hospital pass out for the night and leave Teagan in the staff's care, as she'd have done when Kayla was born the year before? As far as Kelly's defence team was concerned, she wasn't someone who would even think of murdering a baby, let alone go through with it. Along with the question of motive was the question of whether Kelly was suffering from any form of mental illness that could have contributed to her actions. Throughout the investigation into Teegigen's whereabouts, Kelly had refused to attend counselling or undergo a psychological evaluation. The closest she came was during the 2004 coronial inquest when her parents summoned a general practitioner to their home because Kelly was
如果凯莉真的想参加婚礼，那她为什么不申请一晚的医院通行证，把蒂根交给工作人员照顾呢？就像前一年凯拉出生时她所做的那样。在凯莉的辩护团队看来，她根本不是那种会想到谋杀婴儿的人，更不用说真的去实施了。除了动机问题，还有一个问题是凯莉是否患有任何可能导致她做出这些行为的精神疾病。在调查蒂根下落的过程中，凯莉一直拒绝接受心理咨询或进行心理评估。她最接近的一次是在2004年的死因研讯期间，当时她的父母叫了一位全科医生到家里，因为凯莉处于
in a state of distress. Kelly told the doctor that she was confused and scared and didn't know how to handle the situation she was in. She regretted not telling her parents about the pregnancies, but there had been a lot of expectations on her in regards to her sporting career. Kelly said she'd gotten caught up in the expectations when deep down she wasn't happy and wanted something different from her life. The GP formed the view that Kelly's pregnancies were a cry for love. Instead of talking about how she was feeling, he thought the pregnancies were a dysfunctional way of trying to manage the situation. The doctor stated,
痛苦之中。凯莉告诉医生，她感到困惑和害怕，不知道该如何处理自己所处的境地。她后悔没有告诉父母自己怀孕的事，但她在体育生涯方面背负了太多的期望。凯莉说，她被这些期望所困，而内心深处她并不快乐，想要过不一样的生活。这位全科医生认为，凯莉的怀孕是一种对爱的呼唤。他认为，这些怀孕并不是在表达自己的感受，而是一种试图应对现状的失调方式。医生表示，
I think she was just scared, and it was a nebulous kind of fear. Keen to further understand Kelly's motivations, prosecutors hired a renowned psychiatrist to review Kelly's entire file, including her medical records and police interviews. While he never interviewed Kelly himself, based on the information at hand, the psychiatrist concluded that there was nothing in Kelly's behaviour that indicated any kind of psychiatric or mental illness. She was well aware of her actions and knew the difference between right and wrong. However, he believed that Kelly likely did have some kind of personality disorder. The psychiatrist suspected the two abortions Kelly had as a teenager were formative.
我想她当时只是害怕，那是一种模糊的恐惧。为了进一步了解凯利的动机，检方聘请了一位知名精神科医生审查凯利的全部档案，包括她的医疗记录和警方访谈记录。虽然他从未亲自采访过凯利，但根据现有信息，这位精神科医生得出结论：凯利的行为中没有任何迹象表明她患有任何精神或心理疾病。她完全清楚自己的行为，也知道是非对错。然而，他认为凯利很可能患有某种人格障碍。这位精神科医生怀疑凯利在青少年时期做的两次流产手术对她产生了深远影响。
He believed that after terminating those pregnancies, Kelly developed a desire to be pregnant in order to have the baby she could not have. Each of the babies she subsequently carried to full term were the result of what the psychiatrist labelled a repetition compulsion. He believed that by putting herself back in an unresolved state of conflict, Kelly hoped to correct the previous emotionally distressing experience by managing each subsequent pregnancy more successfully. While he acknowledged that such behaviour defied rational explanation and was extremely destructive, he said the compulsion to repeat behaviour was powerful. he said the compulsion to repeat behaviour was powerful. Kelly Lane's trial for the murder of her newborn baby Tegan Lane commenced in August 2010.
他认为，在终止这些妊娠后，凯利产生了一种怀孕的渴望，想要生下她无法拥有的孩子。她随后足月生下的每一个孩子，都是精神科医生所称的“强迫性重复”的结果。他认为，通过让自己回到一种未解决的冲突状态，凯利希望通过更成功地管理随后的每一次怀孕，来纠正之前那段令人痛苦的情感经历。虽然他承认这种行为无法用理性解释，且极具破坏性，但他表示，这种重复行为的强迫感非常强大。凯利·莱恩因谋杀新生儿蒂根·莱恩而受审的案件于2010年8月开始。
By this point, Kelly was 35 years old and her daughter Emily was nine. If convicted, Kelly faced a minimum of 10 years in prison, meaning that in the best case scenario, Emily would be 19 by the time she got out. Worst case scenario, Kelly faced life behind bars. To safeguard against any possible delays, the potential jury pool was four times the usual amount, with each prospective member carefully hand-picked to ensure they held no moral opinions about abortion or adoption that could impact Kelly's right to a fair trial. The judge firmly told the prospective jurors, the fact that this trial will raise highly emotional issues relating to a mother's dealing with newborn children must not interfere with the presumption of innocence, to which Kelly Lane is emphatically entitled.
此时，凯利已经35岁，她的女儿艾米丽9岁。如果罪名成立，凯利将面临至少10年的监禁，这意味着在最好的情况下，艾米丽在她出狱时也将19岁了。最坏的情况是，凯利将面临终身监禁。为了防止任何可能的延误，潜在的陪审团人数是平时的四倍，每一位候选成员都经过精心挑选，以确保他们对堕胎或收养没有可能影响凯利获得公平审判权利的道德偏见。法官坚定地告诉陪审团候选人，此案将引发与母亲处理新生儿问题相关的强烈情感争议，但这绝不能干扰无罪推定的原则，凯利·莱恩理应享有这一权利。
People of all ages, genders and backgrounds asked to be excused until there were just 12 individuals left, with two serving as backup. The prosecution was led by Mark Tedeschi, a formidable senior-crown prosecutor who'd secured convictions in some of the nation's most high-profile trials, including the Belanglo backpacker murders as covered in episode 109 of Casefile, and the Gonzales family murders as covered in episode 103 of Casefile. Over three days, Tedeschi presented a highly detailed account of Kelly Lane's secret pregnancies and the subsequent lies she told. As for how she managed to become pregnant so many times while taking the contraceptive pill,
来自各行各业、不同年龄和性别的人们请求免除陪审义务，直到只剩下12人，另有两人作为候补。检方由马克·特德斯基领导，他是一位令人敬畏的资深皇家检察官，曾在该国一些最引人注目的审判中获得定罪，包括《Casefile》第109集报道的贝兰格洛背包客谋杀案，以及第103集报道的冈萨雷斯家族谋杀案。在三天的时间里，特德斯基详细陈述了凯利·莱恩秘密怀孕及其随后撒下的谎言。至于她在服用避孕药的情况下是如何多次怀孕的，
Tedeschi theorised that the pill had been rendered ineffective because of Kelly's frequent binge drinking in her younger years which often resulted in her vomiting. She would regularly go out to the pub and she used to keep up with the boys in her drinking, he explained. Tedeschi submitted to the jury that it was clear from the get-go that Kelly never had any intention of bringing Teigen home. The jury could therefore rule out any other possible reasons for the newborn's death, such as accident or misadventure. Instead, Tedeschi presented that Kelly didn't want to go through with the emotionally gruelling and time-consuming adoption process again, so either shortly before or after leaving the hospital with Teigen, she formed the intention to kill her. Tedeschi told the jury,
特德斯基推测，由于凯利年轻时经常酗酒，导致她频繁呕吐，避孕药因此失效。他解释说，她经常去酒吧，而且在喝酒方面不输给男生。特德斯基向陪审团提交证据称，从一开始就很清楚，凯利从未打算把蒂根带回家。因此，陪审团可以排除新生儿死亡的其他任何可能原因，例如意外或不幸。相反，特德斯基提出，凯利不想再经历一次情感上极其折磨且耗时的收养过程，所以她在离开医院时，或是在离开医院前不久，就形成了杀害蒂根的意图。特德斯基告诉陪审团，
Tedeschi told the jury, We don't know how or where the accused killed Teigen or how she disposed of the body. However, the Auburn Hospital was just a couple of kilometres away from what was then the Homebush Olympics site, which at that time in 1996 was surrounded by vast swathes of vacant land, a few building sites and deserted roads, particularly at the weekend. So there was an opportunity nearby for the accused to find somewhere that was entirely private, which would have given her an opportunity to kill Teigen and dispose of the body. He said the fact that Kelly attended a wedding straight after and was able to move on like nothing ever happened showed, quote, either a callous disregard for human life or a complete
特德斯基告诉陪审团，我们不知道被告是如何或在哪里杀害蒂根的，也不知道她是如何处理尸体的。然而，奥本医院距离当时霍姆布什奥运会场址仅几公里之遥，在1996年那个时候，那里被大片空地、几个建筑工地和荒凉的道路所包围，尤其是在周末。因此，被告在附近有机会找到一个完全私密的地方，这让她有机会杀害蒂根并处理尸体。他说，凯利在事后直接去参加婚礼，并且表现得好像什么都没发生过一样，这表明，引用他的话，“要么是对人类生命冷酷无情的漠视，要么是完全
ability to block out the terrible act she had just committed. However, the prosecution did think that Kelly's actions took an emotional toll. Tedeschi told the jury that when Kelly gave birth to Jacob the following year, quote, "...the experience of killing Tegan had been so awful that even the practical difficulties involved in an adoption were preferable to killing another child. The defence objected to Tadeski's scenario involving the Homebush Olympic site. At no point was this location ever searched by police and there was nothing to suggest Kelly had gone there after leaving Auburn Hospital. The judge agreed to the objection and Tedeschi was ordered to withdraw this remark. He told the jury to disregard that specific scenario, stating, There is no evidence at all as to what happened to Tegan or the accused during those three plus
能够屏蔽掉她刚刚犯下的可怕罪行。”然而，检方确实认为凯利的行为造成了情感上的代价。特德斯基告诉陪审团，当凯利在次年产下雅各布时，引用他的话：“……杀害蒂根的经历太可怕了，以至于即使是收养过程中涉及的实际困难，也比杀害另一个孩子要好。”辩方对特德斯基关于霍姆布什奥运会场址的假设提出了反对。警方从未搜查过该地点，也没有任何迹象表明凯利在离开奥本医院后去过那里。法官同意了这一反对意见，并命令特德斯基撤回这一言论。他告诉陪审团忽略那个特定的假设，并指出：“对于蒂根或被告在离开医院前中午到下午3点到达她父母家那三个多小时里发生了什么，根本没有任何证据。”
hours between when she left the hospital before midday, to use her own words, and when she arrived at her parents' house at Fairlight at 3pm. I think it is fair to say, ladies and gentlemen, that it would not be appropriate for you to speculate about what might have happened during that time. Kelly's defence lawyer reminded the jury that there was nothing out of the ordinary about Kelly's sexual behaviour during her youth. He said the only difference between her and the young men she slept with was her ability to become pregnant. The defence maintained that it wasn't up to them to prove that Teigen was still alive.
“女士们，先生们，我认为公平地说，你们对这段时间可能发生的事情进行猜测是不合适的。”凯利的辩护律师提醒陪审团，凯利在年轻时的性行为并没有什么异常。他说，她与她发生关系的年轻男子之间唯一的区别就是她有怀孕的能力。辩方坚持认为，证明蒂根是否还活着不是他们的责任。
Instead, their argument was that the prosecution had failed to provide any evidence to confirm that Teagan was even dead, let alone how she died. And even if Teagan was dead, there was no evidence to suggest that Kelly had killed her. If Teagan had indeed died while under Kelly's care, there was nothing to prove that Kelly had committed any act that demonstrated an intention to seriously harm her. It was entirely possible that Tegan had died by accident. The defense acknowledged it was possible that Kelly was lying about giving Tegan to a man named Andrew Norris or Morris, but even if she was, that didn't
相反，他们的论点是，检方未能提供任何证据来证实蒂根已经死亡，更不用说她是如何死亡的了。即使蒂根确实死了，也没有证据表明是凯利杀害了她。如果蒂根确实是在凯利的照顾下死亡的，也没有证据证明凯利采取了任何表现出严重伤害她意图的行为。蒂根完全有可能是死于意外。辩方承认，凯利可能在把蒂根交给一个叫安德鲁·诺里斯或莫里斯的人这件事上撒了谎，但即使她撒了谎，那也不
mean she had murdered the child. Perhaps she was lying to protect the real identity of the person or people she'd given Tegan to. It was possible the only reason those people hadn't come forward was due to shame. The trial dragged on for three months, during which the prosecution called 75 witnesses, including former friends of Kelly's, her parents, two ex-boyfriends, hospital staff, social workers, and employees from the adoption agencies Kelly had worked with. Despite all the lies she'd told, witnesses described her as a well-raised, polite and upstanding member of the community. Those who knew her, including those who'd since distanced themselves from her, were adamant that she would never hurt a child. While Kelly's conduct during her younger years certainly raised eyebrows amongst some in
意味着她谋杀了这个孩子。也许她撒谎是为了保护她把蒂根交给的那个人或那些人的真实身份。那些人没有站出来，唯一的原因可能是出于羞耻。审判持续了三个月，期间检方传唤了75名证人，包括凯利以前的朋友、她的父母、两名前男友、医院工作人员、社会工作者以及凯利曾工作过的收养机构的员工。尽管她撒了谎，但证人们仍将她描述为一位教养良好、礼貌且正直的社区成员。那些认识她的人，包括那些后来与她疏远的人，都坚称她绝不会伤害孩子。虽然凯利年轻时的行为确实在一些人中引起了质疑，
the courtroom, it was also observed that many seemed to take pity on her and the way in which her private life was being so openly discussed. As time went by, media interest began to dwindle, as many journalists formed the opinion that a murder conviction was unlikely. Meanwhile, birth certificates continued to trickle in as a result of the nationwide school inquiries, prompting criticism from the judge about the prosecution's handling. Multiple times the trial was put on hold while leads were followed up and evidence was debated for admissibility. The defence called no witnesses and Kelly didn't take the stand.
但在法庭上，人们也观察到许多人似乎对她以及她的私生活被如此公开地讨论感到同情。随着时间的推移，媒体的兴趣开始减弱，因为许多记者认为定罪的可能性不大。与此同时，随着全国范围内的学校调查，出生证明不断涌现，这引发了法官对检方处理方式的批评。审判多次被搁置，以便跟进线索并辩论证据的可采性。辩方没有传唤任何证人，凯利也没有出庭作证。
By the time closing arguments commenced, the defence had argued that the case should be thrown out completely. Mark Tedeschi for the prosecution told the jury, Mark Tedeschi for the prosecution told the jury, There is only one person in the world who really knows what happened to baby Tegan, and that is Kelly Lane. She has given many different versions to the authorities, and all of them can be shown to be lies. There is only one reason why she has told all those lies and that is because she was responsible for Tegan's death and she had no other information that could result in Tegan being found alive. The truth was, and still is, dreadful. The jury was dismissed to begin deliberations on Monday December 6 2010. dismissed to begin deliberations on Monday December 6 2010. As days passed by with no verdict reached, Kelly's legal team felt optimistic. This meant the jury was still
当结案陈词开始时，辩方主张应完全驳回此案。检方马克·特德斯基告诉陪审团，检方马克·特德斯基告诉陪审团，世界上只有一个人真正知道蒂根宝宝发生了什么，那就是凯利·莱恩。她向当局提供了许多不同的版本，所有这些都被证明是谎言。她撒下所有这些谎言只有一个原因，那就是她对蒂根的死负有责任，而且她没有其他任何信息能证明蒂根还活着。事实曾经是，现在依然是，令人恐惧的。陪审团于2010年12月6日星期一被解散开始审议。随着日子一天天过去，仍未达成裁决，凯利的法律团队感到乐观。这意味着陪审团仍在
deliberating, which could be favourable for Kelly. It was a whole week before the court was reassembled. For the three perjury charges, they had no doubt Kelly was guilty. However, when it came to the murder charge, the jury was unable to reach a unanimous decision. Kelly wept as the judge told the jury that if they were willing he would accept a majority verdict. Again, the jury was dismissed for further deliberation. Tension was high in the packed courtroom when they reassembled two hours later, with many wondering if there would be a hung jury and therefore a possible retrial. The visibly nervous foreman stood and quietly delivered the verdict. Guilty.
审议中，这对凯利可能是有利的。法庭重新开庭已是一周之后。对于三项伪证罪，他们毫无疑问凯利是有罪的。然而，当谈到谋杀罪时，陪审团无法达成一致意见。当法官告诉陪审团如果他们愿意，他将接受多数裁决时，凯利哭了。陪审团再次被解散进行进一步审议。两小时后他们重新开庭时，挤满的法庭内气氛紧张，许多人想知道是否会出现悬案陪审团，从而可能导致重审。明显紧张的陪审团长站起来，平静地宣读了裁决。有罪。
The courtroom's silence was shattered by the screams of Kelly's mother, Sandra, while Kelly herself let out a low moan before collapsing hard onto the floor, banging her head on the way down. It took paramedics 15 minutes to get her back into her seat, at which point the judge denied bail. Kelly was taken into custody to await sentencing, which was scheduled to take place in three months' time. The unexpected guilty verdict propelled the case back into the headlines. After years of avoiding interviews and declining to testify in both the coronial inquest and the trial, Kelly went to the media to share her story once and for all. Kelly's new boyfriend Patrick began recording the couple's phone calls with her permission
法庭的寂静被凯利母亲桑德拉的尖叫声打破，而凯利本人发出一声低沉的呻吟，随后重重地瘫倒在地，倒下时撞到了头。医护人员花了15分钟才让她回到座位上，此时法官拒绝了保释。凯利被拘留等待判决，判决定于三个月后进行。意想不到的有罪判决使此案再次成为头条新闻。在多年回避采访并拒绝在死因裁判官调查和审判中作证后，凯利向媒体分享了她的故事。凯利的新男友帕特里克在她的许可下开始录制两人的通话，
and handed the audio over to Channel 7's Sunday Night program. Kelly said she felt like she was being punished for being pregnant or placing babies for adoption, telling Patrick, It's hard to understand why I'm still being raked over the coals for it. It's hard to understand why I'm still being raked over the coals for it." As for the prosecution's case that Andrew Norris never existed, Kelly scoffed, well I don't know how Tegan came about if he didn't exist. I didn't make her by myself. She criticised the police investigation, saying not enough was done to find Andrew or Tegan, and was scathing about the fact that searches were still being held during her trial.
并将音频交给了第七频道的《周日之夜》节目。凯利说她觉得因为怀孕或将孩子送去收养而受到惩罚，她告诉帕特里克：“很难理解为什么我至今仍因此被严厉指责。”至于检方关于安德鲁·诺里斯从未存在过的论点，凯利嘲笑道：“如果他不存在，我不知道蒂根是怎么来的。我不是一个人造出她的。”她批评了警方的调查，称在寻找安德鲁或蒂根方面做得不够，并对审判期间仍在进行搜查的事实表示尖锐批评。
To put Kelly's word to the test, Sunday Night announced they would fund a $500,000 reward for information leading to the whereabouts of Tegan Lane or Andrew Norris. Kelly was hopeful that this would provide the breakthrough she needed, telling Patrick. Someone might ring in now that hasn't seen the news before or didn't put two and two together and have some information that either leads straight to Andrew or to Tegan now that she's old enough to have her own connections to people. It wasn't just Kelly who was critical of the investigation. Prominent criminal defence lawyer Chris Murphy told Sunday Night that prosecutor Mark Tedeschi poisoned the case when he wrongly speculated to the jury that Kelly killed Teigen and dumped her body at the Homebush Olympic site.
为了检验凯利的话，第七频道宣布将提供50万澳元的悬赏，以获取有关蒂根·莱恩或安德鲁·诺里斯下落的信息。凯利希望这将带来她所需要的突破，她告诉帕特里克：“现在可能会有人打电话进来，他们之前没看过新闻，或者没把两件事联系起来，现在可能有一些信息，要么直接指向安德鲁，要么指向蒂根，因为她现在已经长大了，可以有自己的社交联系了。”不仅凯利对调查持批评态度。著名刑事辩护律师克里斯·墨菲告诉《周日之夜》，检察官马克·特德斯基在向陪审团错误地推测凯利杀害了蒂根并将尸体丢弃在霍姆布什奥运会场址时，毒害了整个案件。
Even though this statement was withdrawn, Chris Murphy said it planted an idea in the minds of the jury that the prosecution knew more than they were letting on. I find the Kelly Lane case the most disturbing case I've ever come across, Chris said. This woman has no history of violence. There's absolutely no evidence whatsoever that she killed that baby, or that that baby died. I could not in a million years under any circumstance safely conclude that she killed the baby deliberately to the high degree of proof required for murder. to the high degree of proof required for murder. Kelly hasn't wanted to say what has happened to the baby. That doesn't mean she is guilty of murder. Nothing came of the reward offer and
尽管这一陈述被撤回，但克里斯·墨菲表示，这在陪审团心中植入了一个想法，即检方知道的比他们透露的要多。“我发现凯利·莱恩案是我遇到过的最令人不安的案件，”克里斯说。“这个女人没有暴力史。绝对没有任何证据表明她杀害了那个婴儿，或者那个婴儿已经死亡。在任何情况下，我都不可能在一百万年内安全地得出结论，认为她为了谋杀罪所需的高证明标准而蓄意杀害了婴儿。”凯利不想说出婴儿发生了什么。这并不意味着她犯有谋杀罪。悬赏提议没有任何结果，
Kelly's sentencing went ahead in April 2011. While the judge didn't believe Kelly's actions were the highest or lowest form of criminal culpability, he acknowledged there were two serious aggravating factors to take into consideration. Namely, the life taken was that of a defenceless baby, and that baby met her end at the hands of her mother. Quote, "...a person from whom she could ordinarily expect protection, sustenance, and care. He stated that even without knowing how Tegan met her death, he was, quote, satisfied beyond reasonable doubt that some time after Kelly left the hospital she formed the intention to take the child's life, and did so very soon after forming that intention. The judge clarified,
凯利的判决于2011年4月进行。虽然法官不认为凯利的行为属于最高或最低程度的刑事罪责，但他承认有两个严重的加重情节需要考虑。即，被剥夺的生命是一个手无寸铁的婴儿，而那个婴儿死于她母亲之手。引用他的话：“……一个她本应期望获得保护、供养和照顾的人。”他指出，即使不知道蒂根是如何死亡的，他也“确信无疑，在凯利离开医院后的某个时间，她形成了剥夺孩子生命的意图，并在形成该意图后不久就付诸实施。”法官澄清说，
it suggests a relatively, although not completely, spontaneous act. Putting it bluntly, Kelly must have found herself in a desperate situation and could see no way out. From her perspective, irrational though it was, there was simply no way out. I find that the offence was premeditated, but only for a short time. It was committed in a situation of desperation arising from a sense of entrapment and isolation and a perceived inability to communicate with the very people who would have eased her burden and helped her out of the desperate situation in which she found herself. Irrational though these feelings were, I accept that they were likely to have been experienced by Kelly.
“这表明这是一种相对的，尽管不是完全的，自发行为。”直言不讳地说，凯利一定发现自己处于绝望的境地，看不到出路。从她的角度来看，尽管是不理性的，但确实没有出路。我认定该罪行是预谋的，但时间很短。它是在一种因被困感和孤立感，以及认为无法与那些本可以减轻她负担并帮助她走出困境的人沟通而产生的绝望情况下犯下的。尽管这些感觉是不理性的，但我接受凯利很可能确实有过这种感受。
New laws introduced in 2003 put the standard non-parole period for murder at 25 years if the victim was under 18. Taking into account Kelly's immaturity at the time of the killing, the unlikeliness that she'd ever re-offend, and the law that applied when the offence occurred in 1996, the judge stated, "...I am satisfied that Kelly Lane is now a very different person to the troubled personage that lay beneath the Golden Girl exterior." The maturity has probably been cemented, ironically enough, because of the love and devotion that has grown between her and her daughter, Emily. It is a further tragic irony that,
2003年出台的新法律规定，如果受害者未满18岁，谋杀罪的标准不得假释期为25年。考虑到凯利在杀人时的不成熟、她再次犯罪的可能性极小，以及1996年案发时适用的法律，法官表示：“……我确信凯利·莱恩现在与那个隐藏在‘黄金女孩’外表下的困扰的人完全不同。”这种成熟可能已经巩固，讽刺的是，是因为她和女儿艾米丽之间日益增长的爱与奉献。另一个悲剧性的讽刺是，
despite Kelly's maturity, her rehabilitation and the apparent resolution of the difficulties that beset her in her youth, she must now face a lengthy period in prison. With that, he sentenced Kelly Lane to 18 years. As Kelly was led from the court, a man's voice rang out from amongst the spectators. I'll help you, he called. court. Days after Kelly's sentencing, Chris Murphy, the criminal lawyer who appeared on Channel 7's Sunday Night Program to discuss Teigen's case, was contacted by a man named Maurice who claimed to have some important information. According to Maurice, in 1996, he was working in Sydney as a taxi driver. On Saturday September 14, he picked Kelly and her newborn baby up from Auburn Hospital
尽管凯利已经成熟，她的康复以及她年轻时所困扰的困难似乎已经解决，但她现在必须面对漫长的监禁。至此，他判处凯利·莱恩18年监禁。当凯利被带离法庭时，观众中传出一个男人的声音。“我会帮你的，”他喊道。凯利被判刑几天后，曾在第七频道《周日之夜》节目中讨论蒂根案的刑事律师克里斯·墨菲接到了一名自称莫里斯的男子的电话，他声称有一些重要信息。据莫里斯说，1996年，他在悉尼当出租车司机。9月14日星期六，他从奥本医院接上了凯利和她的新生儿，
and began driving them to Manly. As they headed down River Road in Lane Cove, a somewhat isolated stretch of bushland, Kelly asked Maurice to pull over. She got out, bringing the baby with her. When she returned a few minutes later, she was alone. Kelly allegedly told Maurice she'd given the newborn to a babysitter. Not thinking much of it, Maurice continued the drive to Manly. When Kelly got out of the car, he noticed that she'd left a baby bag full of nappies on the back seat. Maurice called out to Kelly,
并开始开车送她们去曼利。当他们沿着兰科夫的河路行驶时，那是一段相对偏僻的丛林地带，凯利要求莫里斯靠边停车。她下了车，带着婴儿一起。几分钟后她回来时，只有她一个人。据称凯利告诉莫里斯，她把新生儿交给了一个保姆。莫里斯没多想，继续开车前往曼利。当凯利下车时，他注意到她把一个装满尿布的婴儿包留在了后座上。莫里斯喊住凯利，
but she responded, I don't need it. Suspicious about this comment, Maurice claimed he returned to the spot on River Road where Kelly exited with the baby. In a patch of nearby bushland he found the baby and a bottle wrapped up in a blanket next to a tree. A woman passed by and Maurice spoke to her. He said he was going to contact the police, but the woman offered to take care of it. Maurice handed the baby over and didn't give it much more thought. It was only when he saw Kelly Lane's murder trial in the news that he recognised her face and realised the significance of this moment. Chris Murphy encouraged Maurice to go to the police with this information and then went
但她回答说：“我不需要它。”对这一评论感到怀疑的莫里斯声称，他回到了河路上凯利带着婴儿下车的地方。在附近的一片丛林中，他发现婴儿和一个包裹在毯子里的奶瓶放在一棵树旁。一名妇女经过，莫里斯与她交谈。他说他要联系警察，但那名妇女主动提出处理这件事。莫里斯把婴儿交给了她，没再多想。直到他在新闻中看到凯利·莱恩的谋杀案审判时，他才认出她的脸，并意识到这一时刻的重要性。克里斯·墨菲鼓励莫里斯带着这些信息去警察局，然后公开了这些说法。
public with the claims. Kelly's legal team rejected this scenario, saying, We are aware of the taxi driver's claims but have no interest in pursuing that line of inquiry. The police warned that if Maurice was lying, he'd be charged with creating public mischief. Maurice's background was looked into. Not only did he admit to having mental health issues, it turned out that in 1996 he was banned from driving and couldn't possibly have been working as a taxi driver. While Maurice's claims were ruled out, Kelly appealed her conviction on eight grounds. Although she maintained her innocence, she argued that the judge had erred by failing to leave an alternative count of manslaughter or infanticide to the jury. She also argued that a new jury
凯利的法律团队拒绝了这一说法，称：“我们知道出租车司机的说法，但没有兴趣追查那条线索。”警方警告说，如果莫里斯撒谎，他将被控制造公共骚乱。莫里斯的背景受到了调查。他不仅承认有心理健康问题，而且事实证明，在1996年，他被禁止驾驶，根本不可能从事出租车司机的工作。虽然莫里斯的说法被排除了，但凯利以八项理由对她的定罪提出了上诉。尽管她坚持自己的清白，但她辩称法官未能向陪审团提交过失杀人或杀婴的替代指控，从而犯了错误。她还辩称，
should have been sworn in after Mark Tedeschi's prejudicial comments and that her lawyer should have applied for a separate trial in respect to her perjury charges. Overall, Kelly said the verdict was unreasonable and couldn't be supported by the evidence. The Court of Appeal rejected the application on all eight grounds, with the panel of judges concluding they were satisfied that the evidence established Kelly's guilt beyond reasonable doubt. Kelly sought special leave to appeal to the High Court of Australia. Her request was denied, meaning she'd officially exhausted all her avenues of appeal. meaning she'd officially exhausted all her revenues of appeal. The only option she had left was to apply to the New South Wales Governor for a pardon, and the only way that could happen was if fresh
在马克·特德斯基发表偏见性评论后，应该宣誓组成一个新的陪审团，并且她的律师应该申请就她的伪证指控进行单独审判。总的来说，凯利说裁决是不合理的，证据不支持。上诉法院驳回了所有八项理由的申请，法官小组得出结论，他们确信证据在排除合理怀疑的情况下确立了凯利的罪行。凯利寻求向澳大利亚高等法院提出上诉的特别许可。她的请求被拒绝，这意味着她正式耗尽了所有上诉途径。她剩下的唯一选择是向新南威尔士州总督申请赦免，而这发生的唯一途径是如果能提出新的
and compelling evidence was presented. As one specialist in wrongful convictions told the Australian Women's Weekly, in Kelly's case, that means either Andrew Norris coming forward or Teagan suddenly appearing. Or if Kelly changes her story. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. I love a good deal as much as anyone, but I'm not going to go to extremes just to save a few dollars. It needs to be simple. No hassles.
且令人信服的证据。正如一位冤案专家告诉《澳大利亚妇女周刊》，在凯利的案件中，这意味着要么安德鲁·诺里斯站出来，要么蒂根突然出现。或者如果凯利改变她的说法。Casefile稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集赞助商来支持我们。我和任何人一样喜欢划算的交易，但我不会为了省几块钱而走极端。它需要简单。没有麻烦。
No nonsense. So when Mint Mobile claimed I could get wireless for $15 a month with a three-month plan, I was skeptical. But it really is that simple. From their easy-to-use website to the fast activation process, switching to Mint Mobile is a breeze. The toughest part is waiting on hold to cancel with your old provider. To get started, head over to mintmobile.com slash case file. There you'll see that right now you can get any 3 month plan, including the unlimited plan, for just $15 a month. All plans come with high-speed data, unlimited talk and text and are delivered on the nation's largest 5G network. Plus, you can keep your own phone and bring your existing number
没有废话。所以当Mint Mobile声称我可以通过三个月的套餐以每月15美元的价格获得无线服务时，我是持怀疑态度的。但它确实就是那么简单。从他们易于使用的网站到快速的激活过程，切换到Mint Mobile轻而易举。最困难的部分是等待取消旧供应商的电话。要开始，请前往mintmobile.com斜杠casefile。在那里你会看到，现在你可以以每月仅15美元的价格获得任何3个月的套餐，包括无限套餐。所有套餐都附带高速数据、无限通话和短信，并在全国最大的5G网络上提供。此外，你可以保留自己的手机并携带现有的号码
and contacts. To get this new customer offer and your new 3-month premium wireless plan for just $15 a month, go to Mintmobile.com slash case file. That's Mintmobile.com slash case file. Cut your wireless bill to $15 a month at Mintmobile.com slash case file. $45 upfront payment required equivalent to $15 per month. New customers on first 3-month plan only. Speeds slower above 40GB on unlimited plan. Additional taxes, fees and restrictions apply. See Mint Mobile for details.
和联系人。要获得此新客户优惠以及每月仅15美元的新3个月高级无线套餐，请前往Mintmobile.com斜杠casefile。那是Mintmobile.com斜杠casefile。在Mintmobile.com斜杠casefile将您的无线账单削减至每月15美元。需要预付45美元，相当于每月15美元。仅限首个3个月套餐的新客户。无限套餐超过40GB后速度变慢。适用额外的税费、费用和限制。详情请参阅Mint Mobile。
Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. In 2016, award-winning investigative journalist Caro Meldrum-Hanna opened a letter addressed to her at the Australian Broadcasting Commission offices in Sydney. Dear Ms Meldrum-Hanna, the letter read. My name is Kelly Lane and I have been wrongfully convicted of murdering my baby in 1996. I believe if the public knew the real facts, had all the information and saw the errors and questions that still remain in my case, they may be able to help, perhaps come forward with where Andrew Norris, our child, or his family are.
感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供高质量的内容。2016年，屡获殊荣的调查记者卡罗·梅尔德鲁姆-汉娜在悉尼澳大利亚广播公司办公室收到了一封寄给她的信。信中写道：“亲爱的梅尔德鲁姆-汉娜女士，我的名字是凯利·莱恩，我因1996年谋杀我的婴儿而被错误定罪。我相信如果公众知道真实的事实，掌握了所有信息，并看到了我案件中仍然存在的错误和疑问，他们也许能够提供帮助，也许能站出来说明安德鲁·诺里斯、我们的孩子或他的家人在哪里。”
Ultimately, we are trying to locate Andrew, our daughter, or a family member. Caro wasn't sure what to make of the letter. She was well known for her work on the ABC's popular current affairs program, Four Corners, but she'd never covered Tegan Lane's case before, so her first thought was that the letter must be a prank. Caro contacted Kelly in prison and confirmed the letter was legitimate. When asked if there was any way she could have harmed Tegan, Kelly responded firmly, There is no way. There is no way. If Andrew didn't turn up, I would have just left her there, or I would have gone down
最终，我们正在努力寻找安德鲁、我们的女儿或家庭成员。卡罗不确定该如何看待这封信。她因在ABC受欢迎的时事节目《四角》中的工作而闻名，但她以前从未报道过蒂根·莱恩的案件，所以她的第一个想法是这封信一定是恶作剧。卡罗在监狱里联系了凯利，并确认这封信是真实的。当被问及是否有任何方式她可能伤害了蒂根时，凯利坚定地回答：“绝无可能。绝无可能。如果安德鲁没有出现，我只会把她留在那里，或者我会走上
the exact same path as before. I would have just left her there, or I would have gone down the exact same path as before, I would have asked for some help, I would have asked to see an adoption agency, and I would have done the exact same thing I did 18 months earlier. I remember that day clear as. I know a lot of people think I'm cold and callous, but those children were very important to me and I loved them. I thought I was doing the right thing by them." Caro agreed to make a documentary about the case which would be titled Exposed! The Case of Kelly Lane, but only under the condition that no topic was off limits and she would follow the truth wherever it led.
和以前完全一样的道路。我只会把她留在那里，或者我会走上和以前完全一样的道路，我会寻求一些帮助，我会要求见收养机构，我会做我18个月前做过的完全一样的事情。我记得那天记得很清楚。我知道很多人认为我冷酷无情，但那些孩子对我来说非常重要，我爱他们。我以为我在为他们做正确的事。”卡罗同意制作一部关于此案的纪录片，片名为《曝光！凯利·莱恩案》，但条件是没有任何话题是禁区，她将跟随真相走向任何地方。
Kelly agreed, and in turn, she handed over her entire case file and court records, including private correspondence sent between herself and her defence team. Caro and a small team fully immersed themselves in the case. They tracked down and interviewed anyone and everyone from Kelly's past who was willing to speak with them, including former water polo coaches, teammates, boyfriends, and even her parents. They spoke to the coroner, prosecutors, and homicide squad detectives who worked on Kelly's case, and were handed a USB containing exclusive confidential police files from a secret informant. After nine months of intense research, the exposed team identified several holes in the investigation as well as questionable legal tactics that had them asking, was Kelly Lane wrongfully convicted?
凯利同意了，作为回报，她交出了她的全部案件档案和法庭记录，包括她和她的辩护团队之间的私人通信。卡罗和一个小团队完全沉浸在这个案件中。他们追踪并采访了凯利过去愿意与他们交谈的任何人，包括前水球教练、队友、男朋友，甚至她的父母。他们与负责凯利案件的验尸官、检察官和凶杀组侦探进行了交谈，并获得了一个包含来自秘密线人的独家机密警方文件的USB。经过九个月的深入研究，曝光团队发现了调查中的几个漏洞以及令人质疑的法律策略，这让他们不禁要问：凯利·莱恩是被错误定罪了吗？
During Kelly's trial, police claimed that exhaustive efforts had been made to interview all the former tenants of the apartment building on Whisbeard Street where Kelly said Andrew Norris had lived. None of the tenants recalled ever seeing Kelly there, nor did they have any knowledge of a resident called Andrew Norris. One former tenant did testify to seeing mail addressed to Andrew Norris as well as Andrew Morris, but his claims were discounted as he'd given various inconsistent statements over the years. However, the exposed team discovered that there was at least one tenant who had never been questioned, a man named Darryl Hanson. The team tracked Darryl down on Facebook and organised a video meeting. When Caro Meldrum-Hanna showed Darryl a photo of Kelly Lane taken in about 1996. He claimed he remembered
在凯利的审判期间，警方声称已经进行了详尽的努力，采访了凯利所说的安德鲁·诺里斯居住过的惠斯比尔德街公寓楼的所有前租户。没有租户记得见过凯利，他们也不知道有一个叫安德鲁·诺里斯的居民。一位前租户确实作证说看到了寄给安德鲁·诺里斯以及安德鲁·莫里斯的邮件，但他的说法被忽略了，因为他多年来给出了各种不一致的陈述。然而，曝光团队发现至少有一位租户从未被询问过，一个叫达里尔·汉森的人。团队在Facebook上追踪到了达里尔，并组织了一次视频会议。当卡罗·梅尔德鲁姆-汉娜向达里尔展示了一张凯利·莱恩大约在1996年拍摄的照片时，他声称他记得
seeing her around the building. Darryl said he used to spend a lot of time in the downstairs car park working on his car late at night. He remembered seeing Kelly exit the building through the car park several times, sometimes as late as 1am. Darryl claimed he saw Kelly so many times that he thought she must have lived in the building. When pressed by Caro as to whether he could be misremembering in hindsight, Darryl insisted Kelly Lane was the person he had seen. He was so sure that he said he'd happily testify that in a court of law. The exposed team also interviewed a childhood friend of Kelly's named Natalie McCauley, who had recently appeared on 60 Minutes in Kelly's defense. Natalie claimed that she remembered the summer of 1996 very clearly, as it was the year that she and all her friends had turned 21. Early in the year,
在楼里见过她。达里尔说他过去经常在楼下的停车场花很多时间在深夜修车。他记得多次看到凯利穿过停车场离开大楼，有时甚至晚到凌晨1点。达里尔声称他看到凯利很多次，以至于他认为她一定住在这栋楼里。当卡罗追问他是否可能事后记错了时，达里尔坚持认为凯利·莱恩就是他见过的那个人。他非常确定，以至于他说他很乐意在法庭上作证。曝光团队还采访了凯利的一位童年朋友，名叫娜塔莉·麦考利，她最近在《60分钟》节目中为凯利辩护。娜塔莉声称她记得1996年的夏天非常清楚，因为那是她和所有朋友满21岁的那一年。年初，
Kelly allegedly confided in Natalie that she was having a fling with another man. She mentioned it at least three times over a one-month period. Natalie said she remembered the name of Kelly's secret lover clearly, as he had the same first name as Natalie's brother, Andrew. Natalie claimed that she'd provided police with this information during the investigation and she'd also been willing to testify in Kelly's defence at trial. However, she believed the police weren't interested because they were already convinced of Kelly's guilt. Addament that she wouldn't lie about such a thing, especially given her profession in child protection, Natalie told Exposed, "...I am passionate about children's rights. I love children.
凯利据称向娜塔莉吐露她正在与另一个男人有染。她在一个月内至少提到了三次。娜塔莉说她清楚地记得凯利秘密情人的名字，因为他和娜塔莉的兄弟安德鲁名字相同。娜塔莉声称她在调查期间向警方提供了这些信息，并且她也愿意在审判中为凯利的辩护作证。然而，她认为警方不感兴趣，因为他们已经确信凯利有罪。娜塔莉坚称她不会在这种事情上撒谎，特别是考虑到她在儿童保护领域的职业，她告诉《曝光》：“……我对儿童权利充满热情。我爱孩子。
Every day my waking hour is about protecting kids. I'm not about to let my friend get off easy if she's hurt a child." During the search for Teagan's father, police had also spoken to a man named Andrew Morris who recalled visiting Sydney's northern beaches for a surf life saving competition in the mid-1990s. When shown a photo line up of several young women, Andrew Morris recognised Kelly Lane but couldn't be sure how or why. He told the exposed team that the police then began drip feeding him information about Kelly until he put two and two together and realised that they once had a random one-off sexual encounter at the North Narebeen Surf Club.
我每天醒着的每一小时都是为了保护孩子。如果我的朋友伤害了孩子，我绝不会让她轻易脱身。”在寻找蒂根父亲的过程中，警方还与一名叫安德鲁·莫里斯的男子交谈过，他回忆起在90年代中期访问悉尼北部海滩参加冲浪救生比赛。当被展示几名年轻女性的照片阵容时，安德鲁·莫里斯认出了凯利·莱恩，但无法确定是如何或为什么。他告诉曝光团队，警方随后开始向他滴灌有关凯利的信息，直到他把两件事联系起来，意识到他们曾经在北纳里宾冲浪俱乐部有过一次随机的性接触。
It had happened around the same time that Teigen would have been conceived. Andrew had been scheduled to testify for the prosecution at Kelly's trial, not to suggest he was Teigen's father, but to explain how Kelly came up with the Andrew Morris or Norris persona in the first place. Then at the last minute, a deal was made between both legal teams. Andrew wouldn't testify, and neither would Natalie McCauley. This was just one of several factors that led Kelly's case to being taken on by the Bridge of Hope Innocence Initiative, an organisation dedicated to examining possible wrongful convictions.
这发生在蒂根可能受孕的同一时间。安德鲁原定在凯利的审判中为检方作证，不是为了暗示他是蒂根的父亲，而是为了解释凯利最初是如何想出安德鲁·莫里斯或诺里斯这个角色的。然后在最后一刻，双方法律团队达成了一项协议。安德鲁不会作证，娜塔莉·麦考利也不会。这只是导致凯利的案件被“希望之桥无罪倡议”接手的几个因素之一，该组织致力于审查可能的错误定罪。
A spokesperson for the initiative told Exposed about the deal relating to Natalie McCauley and Andrew Morris. For Kelly's supporters, these allegations of witness coaching, witness swapping and deals struck between the prosecution and defence were further evidence that Kelly hadn't received a fair trial. Exposed also unearthed records from Auburn Hospital that cast doubt on the timing of Kelly's departure with baby Teagan. Notes made by a registered nurse had Kelly leaving at 2pm. That same nurse later provided a statement saying Kelly was discharged between 11am and 12 midday. If the hospital records were correct and Kelly really had left the hospital at 2pm and was home
该倡议的一位发言人告诉《曝光》，关于涉及娜塔莉·麦考利和安德鲁·莫里斯的交易。对于凯利的支持者来说，这些关于证人辅导、证人交换以及检方和辩方之间达成的交易的指控，进一步证明了凯利没有得到公平的审判。曝光团队还挖掘出了奥本医院的记录，这些记录对凯利带着蒂根宝宝离开的时间产生了怀疑。一名注册护士做的笔记显示凯利在下午2点离开。同一名护士后来提供了一份声明，称凯利在上午11点到中午12点之间出院。如果医院记录是正确的，凯利确实在下午2点离开医院，并且在下午3点回到
in Fairlight by 3pm, then exposed posited that Kelly wouldn't have had time to kill Teagan and dispose of her body. Even investigators who worked on the case were critical of the way things were handled. Various individuals involved expressed their discomfort with Kelly's conviction. The detective who led the investigation into Teigen's murder had since retired from the force. She told Exposed that police had no evidence against Kelly and weren't ready when the DPP decided to proceed with the murder charge. I used every trick in the book, the former detective explained. An undercover strategy, covert DNA samples, every resource that was available. There was nothing. Absolutely nothing. We didn't have anything. The exposed team also highlighted the fact that for all the digging police did to find
费尔莱特家中，那么曝光团队推测凯利将没有时间杀害蒂根并处理她的尸体。即使是参与此案的调查人员也对处理方式持批评态度。参与其中的不同个人表达了他们对凯利定罪的不安。领导蒂根谋杀案调查的侦探后来从警队退休。她告诉《曝光》，警方没有针对凯利的证据，当刑事检控专员决定继续进行谋杀指控时，他们还没有准备好。“我用了书中的每一个技巧，”这位前侦探解释说。“卧底策略、秘密DNA样本、所有可用的资源。什么都没有。绝对什么都没有。我们什么都没有。”曝光团队还强调了一个事实，即尽管警方为了寻找
Teegans biological father, they never organised for a composite sketch to be made. They questioned why such an image wasn't broadcast around Australia, asking anyone who had seen such a man to come forward. The exposed team organised for a former police officer turned forensic artist to visit Kelly in prison. Kelly recalled Andrew's physical features in detail and a clear composite sketch of Andrew Norris was created for the first time. The forensic artist, who had 18 years experience creating sketches, believed Kelly was truthful
蒂根的亲生父亲进行了挖掘，但他们从未组织制作复合素描。他们质疑为什么这样的图像没有在澳大利亚各地广播，要求任何见过这样的人的人站出来。曝光团队组织了一位转行做司法艺术家的前警官去监狱探望凯利。凯利详细回忆了安德鲁的身体特征，并首次清晰地绘制了安德鲁·诺里斯的复合素描。这位拥有18年素描经验的司法艺术家认为凯利是真实的
in her description. She was consistent throughout, he said. She didn't sway at all. In a phone call from prison, Kelly told Caro Meldrum-Hanna that from a very young age her athletic training taught her to hide her emotions. She was excellent at filing feelings away and being a different person for different people. She also revealed that her first sexual experience was being date raped while intoxicated at the age of 15. Kelly explained, I don't think I valued my body and my choices and my boundaries because everybody just seemed to be so frivolous with it." She struggled upon learning that several people in her life had indeed
在她的描述中。“她始终如一，”他说。“她一点也没有动摇。”在监狱打来的电话中，凯利告诉卡罗·梅尔德鲁姆-汉娜，从很小的时候起，她的运动训练就教她隐藏自己的情绪。她非常擅长将感受归档，并为不同的人扮演不同的人。她还透露，她的第一次性经历是在15岁时醉酒后被约会强奸。凯利解释说：“我不认为我重视我的身体、我的选择和我的界限，因为每个人似乎都对此非常轻率。”她在得知她生活中的几个人确实如此时感到挣扎。
suspected she was pregnant at times but never reached out. While Kelly made it clear she didn't want to shift the responsibility onto others, she asked Caro, Wasn't I worth asking? Why were people afraid, or why did they not want to ask me? It's kind of sad to think that no one reached out and said you seem different, or you look different, or are you okay? or are you okay? As part of the documentary, Kelly agreed to meet face to face with Dr. Ann Buist, a forensic psychiatrist who specialises in women's mental health and the relationship between mother and babies. Throughout her career, Dr. Buist had worked with hundreds of women who'd
有时怀疑她怀孕了，但从未联系过她。虽然凯利明确表示她不想把责任推给别人，但她问卡罗：“难道我不值得被问吗？为什么人们害怕，或者为什么他们不想问我？”想到没有人主动伸出援手说“你看起来不一样了”或者“你还好吗”，这真让人难过。作为纪录片的一部分，凯利同意与法医精神病学家安·布伊斯特博士面对面交流，布伊斯特博士专门研究女性心理健康以及母亲与婴儿之间的关系。在她的职业生涯中，布伊斯特博士曾与数百名女性合作过，她们
been accused of abusing their children, but she said that Kelly was her hardest, most difficult case. Dr Buist told Exposed that she didn't find Kelly to be a pathological liar, a narcissist, or mentally ill. She thought the secret pregnancies could be explained by Kelly's upbringing, during which she'd received the message that her family didn't like dealing with negative emotions. Dr Buist couldn't find a coherent narrative that Kelly could have killed Tegan, aside from the fact that she had demonstrated the capacity to detach from her other children. For Dr Buist, one thing in particular stood out during her interviews with Kelly. When Kelly started talking about Andrew Norris, her body language changed.
被指控虐待自己的孩子，但她说凯利是她处理过的最艰难、最棘手的案例。布伊斯特博士告诉《Exposed》节目，她并不认为凯利是一个病态的撒谎者、自恋者或精神病患者。她认为这些秘密怀孕可以用凯利的成长经历来解释，在成长过程中，她得到的信号是她的家庭不喜欢处理负面情绪。布伊斯特博士无法找到一个连贯的叙述来证明凯利可能杀害了蒂根，除了她确实表现出能够与自己的其他孩子疏远的能力。对于布伊斯特博士来说，在采访凯利时，有一件事特别突出。当凯利开始谈论安德鲁·诺里斯时，她的肢体语言发生了变化。
The way she spoke about him seemed superficial. Dr Buist told Exposed, "...there was something there that didn't ring true. Exposed was released by the ABC in 2018 to rave reviews, propelling Kelly's case back into the spotlight. Members of the public hotly debated Kelly's guilty verdict and shared outrage over what many now viewed as a wrongful conviction. Thousands turned to social media to accuse the prosecution of misconduct and Kelly's defence team of negligence. Calls were made for Kelly to be exonerated or at the very least retried. But the documentary wasn't without its critics. Many were quick to point out that crucial
她谈论他的方式显得很肤浅。布伊斯特博士告诉《Exposed》：“……那里有些东西听起来不真实。”《Exposed》于2018年由澳大利亚广播公司（ABC）发布，获得了热烈反响，将凯利的案件重新推向了聚光灯下。公众热烈讨论凯利的有罪判决，并对许多人现在视为冤案的行为表示愤怒。成千上万的人转向社交媒体，指责检方不当行为和凯利的辩护团队疏忽职守。人们呼吁为凯利平反，或者至少进行重审。但这部纪录片并非没有批评者。许多人很快指出，关键
information was withheld from the viewers, with some accusing the ABC of provoking public excitement at the expense of accurate reporting. Retired Australian barrister Simon Davis was one such critic. Simon hadn't been involved in Kelly's trial in any capacity, but after watching Exposed, he was shocked by the trial's flaws and felt compelled to look into the case in detail. Simon essentially fact-checked the claims made by Exposed, then published a book titled On Trial, The Case of Kelly Lane and the ABC, in which he debunked each one. Casting doubt on the claims made by former Whisbeach Street tenant Darryl Henson, Simon said it was hard to believe a witness could so confidently recognise a stranger two decades
信息对观众隐瞒了，一些人指责ABC为了准确报道而牺牲了公众的兴奋感。退休的澳大利亚大律师西蒙·戴维斯就是这样一位批评者。西蒙没有以任何身份参与凯利的审判，但在观看《Exposed》后，他对审判的缺陷感到震惊，并感到有必要详细调查此案。西蒙基本上核实了《Exposed》提出的主张，然后出版了一本名为《审判中：凯利·莱恩与ABC案》的书，在书中他逐一驳斥了这些主张。对前威斯比奇街租户达里尔·亨森提出的主张表示怀疑，西蒙说很难相信一个证人能在二十年后如此自信地认出一个陌生人，
after the fact, especially when the alleged interactions occurred in the dark of night. Furthermore, while Darryl claimed Kelly usually left in the middle of the night, Kelly had told police that when she'd stayed at Andrew Norris' place she left in the morning and went straight to water polo training. Simon Davis concluded, Ultimately, Henson's evidence was of such low probative value that it is questionable whether it would even be admissible at a trial. Simon Davis rejected the claims about witness swapping and game playing between the opposing legal teams. He pointed out that Exposed had failed to tell their audience several important details regarding Natalie McAuley's
特别是在所谓的互动发生在深夜的情况下。此外，虽然达里尔声称凯利通常在半夜离开，但凯利告诉警方，当她住在安德鲁·诺里斯家时，她是早上离开并直接去参加水球训练的。西蒙·戴维斯总结道：“最终，亨森的证据证明价值极低，以至于它在审判中是否具有可采性都值得怀疑。”西蒙·戴维斯驳斥了关于对立法律团队之间交换证人和玩弄手段的说法。他指出，《Exposed》未能向观众告知关于娜塔莉·麦考利的一些重要细节，
claims. Firstly, in Natalie's original police statement she made no mention of Andrew, despite later stating Kelly told her about Andrew at the time of their affair. Secondly, Natalie was cross-examined by the prosecution at Kelly's pre-trial hearing before the jury was sworn in. Some of the responses she gave led to doubts about her credibility. She was therefore deemed unreliable and not called to testify during the trial. Thirdly, and to Simon Davis most importantly, police had asked Kelly if any of her friends knew about her affair with Andrew. At no point did she mention Natalie's name.
这些细节包括：首先，在娜塔莉最初的警方陈述中，她没有提到安德鲁，尽管后来声称凯利在他们有染时告诉过她关于安德鲁的事。其次，娜塔莉在凯利的审前听证会上受到了检方的盘问，当时陪审团尚未宣誓就职。她给出的一些回答导致人们对她的可信度产生了怀疑。因此，她被认为不可靠，没有被传唤在审判中作证。第三，对西蒙·戴维斯来说最重要的是，警方曾问凯利是否有朋友知道她与安德鲁的婚外情。她从未在任何时候提到过娜塔莉的名字。
Fourthly, if Kelly really did think Natalie's testimony would have been crucial, then why did she make no mention of it when appealing her conviction? According to Simon Davis' research, the Andrew Morris who appeared on Exposed wasn't prevented from giving evidence due to some kind of witness swapping deal. He was stopped because shortly before the trial commenced, it emerged that the random sexual encounter Andrew had at the beach couldn't possibly have been with Kelly. Thus, his testimony was irrelevant. As for the claim that Kelly left Auburn Hospital with Teigen at 2pm,
第四，如果凯利真的认为娜塔莉的证词至关重要，那么为什么她在上诉时没有提到它？根据西蒙·戴维斯的调查，《Exposed》中出现的安德鲁·莫里斯并不是因为某种交换证人的交易而被阻止提供证据。他被阻止是因为在审判开始前不久，事实证明安德鲁在海滩上发生的随机性接触不可能与凯利有关。因此，他的证词是不相关的。至于凯利在下午2点带着蒂根离开奥本医院的说法，
Kelly herself told the police she'd left the hospital, quote, before 12 o'clock sometime. The patient sharing her room also testified that Kelly and Tegan left by 11am. The nurse had listed eight other matters on Kelly's file at 2pm, not just Kelly's departure. Simon Davis pointed out that all these matters hadn't taken place simultaneously. Many likely occurred before 2pm, and the nurse simply recorded the time she was making the notes. Taking these factors and several others into account, Simon Davis concluded that exposed was inaccurate and misleading. He stated, "...legitimate questioning of a jury's verdict is one thing, however, questioning of a verdict which
凯利本人告诉警方，她是在“12点之前某个时候”离开医院的。与她同住一室的病人也作证说，凯利和蒂根在上午11点前就离开了。护士在下午2点在凯利的档案上列出了其他八项事务，而不仅仅是凯利的离开。西蒙·戴维斯指出，所有这些事情并没有同时发生。许多事情很可能发生在下午2点之前，护士只是记录了她做笔记的时间。考虑到这些因素和其他几个因素，西蒙·戴维斯得出结论，《Exposed》是不准确和误导性的。他指出：“……对陪审团的裁决进行合法的质疑是一回事，然而，对一个已经
has twice been the subject of appellate review without real reference to the appealed judgments and by apparently suppressing many of the relevant facts is quite another. Ultimately, exposed was little more than a recycling of old arguments, long since rejected by the courts or disavowed by Kelly herself, and placing them in 2018 and presumably hoping no one noticed their antiquity or knew they had been rejected. Regardless of its criticisms, Exposed raised some thought-provoking questions and led many to wonder if the prosecution really had met the standard of proof required to reach a conviction. The Bridge of Hope Innocence Initiative petitioned the Attorney-General of New South Wales to
两次经过上诉审查的裁决进行质疑，而没有真正参考上诉判决，并且显然隐瞒了许多相关事实，则是另一回事。”最终，《Exposed》只不过是旧论点的循环利用，这些论点早已被法院驳回或被凯利本人否认，并将其置于2018年的背景下，大概是希望没有人注意到它们的陈旧或知道它们已被驳回。尽管受到批评，《Exposed》还是提出了一些发人深省的问题，并让许多人怀疑检方是否真的达到了定罪所需的证明标准。“希望之桥无罪倡议”组织向新南威尔士州总检察长请愿，要求
open a full inquiry into the investigation, prosecution and conviction of Kelly Lane. They also called for an urgent review into the policing and prosecutorial practices that led to Kelly being charged in the first place. Dr Michelle Reuters, a lawyer and spokesperson for the group, told 60 Minutes, "...one of the things I've found the most extraordinary about Kelly Lane's case is that people find it easier to believe that a young mother would kill her child than they would believe her father would accept responsibility for that child and to disappear. Forensic criminologist Dr. Xanthi Mallett spent two years looking into Kelly's case and agreed that an urgent review
对凯利·莱恩的调查、起诉和定罪进行全面调查。他们还呼吁对导致凯利最初被指控的警务和检察实践进行紧急审查。该组织的律师兼发言人米歇尔·路透社博士告诉《60分钟》节目：“……关于凯利·莱恩案，我发现最不可思议的事情之一是，人们更容易相信一位年轻的母亲会杀害自己的孩子，而不是相信她的父亲会承担起那个孩子的责任并消失。”法医犯罪学家赞西·马利特博士花了两年时间调查凯利的案件，并同意需要进行紧急审查。
was needed. She believed that just because Kelly was a liar, it didn't make her a murderer. Dr Mallett told 60 Minutes, I'm not saying Kelly is innocent. I'm not saying she is guilty. All I'm saying is, if she is going to be in prison, let there be evidence for that, or let her out." For the Australian public, one of the most scandalous details about the case was the fact that Kelly had become pregnant five times in seven years despite being on the contraceptive pill. The fact that she determined two pregnancies in the past, one of which was considered a late term, left people wondering why she didn't just do so again instead of proceeding with three secret pregnancies. Others questioned why Kelly didn't
她认为，仅仅因为凯利是个骗子，并不意味着她就是杀人犯。马利特博士告诉《60分钟》：“我不是说凯利是无辜的。我不是说她有罪。我所说的是，如果她要坐牢，那就拿出证据来，否则就放了她。”对于澳大利亚公众来说，此案中最令人震惊的细节之一是凯利在服用避孕药的情况下，七年内怀孕了五次。她过去曾终止过两次妊娠，其中一次被认为是晚期妊娠，这让人们想知道为什么她不再次这样做，而不是继续三次秘密怀孕。其他人质疑为什么凯利不
abstain from sex entirely if she kept finding herself in an undesirable predicament. entirely if she kept finding herself in an undesirable predicament. But the ongoing interest also prompted conversations about whether Kelly Lane was unfairly judged based on her sex life, which ultimately had nothing to do with whether or not she was capable of murder. Many argue that she was subject to trial by media and the prosecution used slut shaming as a strategic device at her trial. Even the DPP who charged Kelly with murder admitted that her case was prosecuted because it raised all sorts of values. The same DPP came under fire from the public when he told ABC's Exposed that he didn't think Kelly presented a risk to other people's babies, but quote, she seemed to be a bit of a risk to the
完全禁欲，如果她一直发现自己处于不理想的困境中。但持续的关注也引发了关于凯利·莱恩是否因为她的性生活而受到不公平评判的讨论，这最终与她是否有能力谋杀无关。许多人认为她受到了媒体审判，检方在审判中将“荡妇羞辱”作为一种战略手段。甚至起诉凯利谋杀的刑事检控专员（DPP）也承认，她的案件之所以被起诉，是因为它引发了各种价值观的讨论。当这位DPP告诉ABC的《Exposed》节目，他认为凯利对其他人的婴儿不构成风险，但“她似乎对
virile young male portion of the community. But the judge who oversaw the trial said it was necessary to lay the facts of Kelly's personal life bare. While he acknowledged this would have been a humiliating and intrusive experience for Kelly and her family, and that the media excitement led to Kelly's life being examined at a prurient level, quote, the fact remains that there is a need to gain insight into the offender's behaviour in an endeavour to gain an understanding of the level of culpability involved in the murder itself. Some of these matters might, at first blush, seem peripheral to the ascertainment of culpability and the assessment of the objective criminality involved, but in truth, I think that the answers to these
社区中精力充沛的年轻男性部分构成了一点风险”时，他受到了公众的抨击。但负责审判的法官表示，有必要公开凯利个人生活的事实。虽然他承认这对凯利和她的家人来说是一种羞辱和侵入性的经历，而且媒体的兴奋导致凯利的生活在窥淫癖的层面上受到审视，但“事实仍然是，有必要深入了解罪犯的行为，以努力了解谋杀本身所涉及的罪责程度。其中一些事项起初可能看起来与确定罪责和评估所涉及的客观犯罪行为无关，但事实上，我认为这些
troublesome questions are highly relevant in that regard. Dr. Zianthy Mallett is one of many who believe Kelly Lane was a victim of trial by media. She has compared Kelly's situation to that of Lindy Chamberlain whose wrongful conviction for the murder of her baby Azaria was covered in episode 136 of Casefile. Dr Mallet believes that, like Lindy, Kelly was scrutinised for not being emotional enough or responding in the way people thought a mother should. She told Women's Weekly, "... clearly Kelly was never in line to win a Mother of the Year award, and she disgraced herself by
棘手问题的答案在这方面是高度相关的。”赞西·马利特博士是许多认为凯利·莱恩是媒体审判受害者的人之一。她将凯利的情况与林迪·张伯伦进行了比较，林迪因谋杀婴儿阿扎里亚而被错误定罪，该案在《Casefile》第136集中有所报道。马利特博士认为，像林迪一样，凯利因为不够情绪化或没有以人们认为母亲应该有的方式做出反应而受到审视。她告诉《妇女周刊》：“……显然凯利从来没有排队赢得年度母亲奖，而且她因为
lying so often and so flagrantly. But it's still a big leap to say she killed her baby. Caro Meldrum Hanna told Mamma Mia that judgment of Kelly's sex life remained one of the prominent discussions when it came to this case. There was a lot of slut-shaming back then, she said, and it's clear there's a lot of slut-shaming now. Nevertheless, Caro told the ABC, I can understand why people are haunted by this case. There's a two-day-old baby at the centre of it. Where is Teigen and what happened to her? There's nothing more vulnerable than a newborn baby. These factors aside, one of the biggest criticisms about Kelly Lane's case is the police handling of the investigation and why it took them so long to commence a search for Teigen or question Kelly
经常且公然撒谎而丢尽了脸。但这距离说她杀了自己的孩子还有很大差距。”卡罗·梅尔德鲁姆·汉娜告诉《Mamma Mia》，对凯利性生活的评判仍然是此案中突出的讨论之一。她说，当时有很多“荡妇羞辱”，很明显现在也有很多。尽管如此，卡罗告诉ABC：“我可以理解为什么人们会被这个案件困扰。中心是一个两天的婴儿。蒂根在哪里？她发生了什么事？没有什么比新生儿更脆弱的了。”撇开这些因素不谈，关于凯利·莱恩案最大的批评之一是警方对调查的处理，以及为什么他们花了这么长时间才开始搜寻蒂根或审问凯利
in the first place. Those who believe Kelly was unfairly convicted don't think enough was done to find Andrew Norris and are critical of the fact that investigators were still searching for Andrew and Teigen while both the Coranule inquest and murder trial were underway. But as the prosecution argued, Kelly essentially sent police on a wild goose chase when she told them Tegan was taken by her father, and any delays were therefore Kelly's fault. Others commended the police's intensive search efforts, attesting they did the most thorough job possible given they were searching for a needle in a haystack. While Kelly's case is polarising, even many who believe in her innocence have serious doubts that Andrew Norris ever existed. As Simon Davis stated in his book,
首先。那些认为凯利被不公正定罪的人认为，在寻找安德鲁·诺里斯方面做得不够，并批评调查人员在科罗努尔调查和谋杀审判进行期间仍在寻找安德鲁和蒂根的事实。但正如检方所辩称的那样，凯利在告诉警方蒂根被她父亲带走时，基本上是让警方进行了一场徒劳的追逐，因此任何延误都是凯利的错。其他人称赞了警方密集的搜寻工作，证明他们在寻找大海捞针的情况下尽了最大努力。虽然凯利的案件具有两极分化性，但即使是许多相信她无罪的人也严重怀疑安德鲁·诺里斯是否真的存在。正如西蒙·戴维斯在他的书中所述，
one is driven to conclude that if Andrew and his mum and Mel do exist, they must be huddled together under a proverbial rock. Never in the annals of crime in Australia, or perhaps anywhere, would there have been so much reaching out, searching for, or imploring of a human being to come forward as there has been for Andrew Morris slash Norris. The case would arguably be the most publicised murder conviction in Australian history, and yet still no sign of Andrew Morris slash Norris. In a phone call to Kelly in prison, Caro Meldrum Hanna said that something didn't add up about the Andrew Norris story.
人们不得不得出结论，如果安德鲁和他的妈妈以及梅尔确实存在，他们一定蜷缩在某个隐喻的石头下。在澳大利亚，或者也许在任何地方的犯罪史上，从来没有像寻找安德鲁·莫里斯（斜杠）诺里斯那样，有如此多的人伸出援手、搜寻或恳求一个人站出来。这可以说是澳大利亚历史上最受关注的谋杀定罪案件，然而仍然没有安德鲁·莫里斯（斜杠）诺里斯的踪迹。在给狱中凯利的一通电话中，卡罗·梅尔德鲁姆·汉娜说，关于安德鲁·诺里斯的故事有些不对劲。
I'm not convinced on this name, Caro told Kelly, and I need you to help me. Kelly became somewhat defensive, insisting that the name of Tegan's father was Andrew Norris, emphasising it was spelt with an N. Caro pressed on, asking if it was possible that Andrew Norris might not be his real name. For the first time in over two decades, Kelly said, Absolutely, absolutely. I don't know 100% if his name was Andrew Norris because I don't know if what he was telling me at the time was the truth or if I've made a mistake. Of course that's a possibility. If Teigen's biological father was really out there, he never came forward.
“我不相信这个名字，”卡罗告诉凯利，“我需要你帮我。”凯利变得有些防御，坚持认为蒂根父亲的名字是安德鲁·诺里斯，强调它是用N拼写的。卡罗继续追问，问安德鲁·诺里斯可能不是他的真名是否可能。二十多年来第一次，凯利说：“绝对，绝对。我不能100%确定他的名字是安德鲁·诺里斯，因为我不知道他当时告诉我的是不是真的，或者我是否犯了错误。当然，这是一种可能性。”如果蒂根的亲生父亲真的在外面，他从未站出来。
never came forward. By March 2024, Kelly Lane was 48 years old. She had served her minimum period of 13 and a half years and was eligible to apply for parole. But just two years earlier, New South Wales passed the No Body No Parole legislation, which prevented any prisoners convicted of murder from receiving parole if they hadn't cooperated by identifying their victims' location. A statement released by Kelly's parole board read, police investigations or other actions to identify the location of Teagan. With that, Kelly's bid for release was denied. Public debate followed with one New South Wales politician describing Kelly Lane as a political prisoner. She told The Guardian,
从未站出来。到2024年3月，凯利·莱恩48岁了。她已经服完了13年半的最低刑期，有资格申请假释。但就在两年前，新南威尔士州通过了“无尸体，无假释”立法，禁止任何被判谋杀罪的囚犯在未通过确定受害者位置进行合作的情况下获得假释。凯利假释委员会发布的一份声明写道：“警方调查或其他行动以确定蒂根的位置。”就这样，凯利的释放申请被拒绝了。随后引发了公众辩论，一位新南威尔士州政客将凯利·莱恩描述为政治犯。她告诉《卫报》：
The no-body, no-parole law undermines the fundamental objective of parole to support community safety with a focus on the rehabilitation of the offender. At their core, they further punish the person who has served their time. The fact is, Kelly Lane has done her time and she has been an exemplary prisoner and she should not remain in prison any longer. Justice Anthony Wheely, the former Supreme Court judge who ever saw Kelly's trial, agreed. In the years since Kelly's conviction, he'd publicly admitted that Kelly's case affected him emotionally. While he accepted the jury's verdict, Justice Whealy said he wasn't
“‘无尸体，无假释’法律破坏了假释的基本目标，即通过关注罪犯的改造来支持社区安全。从本质上讲，它们进一步惩罚了已经服完刑的人。事实是，凯利·莱恩已经服完了刑，她是一个模范囚犯，她不应该再继续待在监狱里了。”曾负责凯利审判的前最高法院法官安东尼·惠利法官表示同意。在凯利被定罪后的几年里，他公开承认凯利的案件在情感上影响了他。虽然他接受了陪审团的裁决，但惠利法官说他并不
convinced that the Crown had proved its case, and he voiced his misgivings about aspects of how the trial was conducted. Since the nobody no parole legislation was passed, Justice Whealy joined many others in calling for changes to this new law. After Kelly's parole was denied, Justice Wheely told a current affair that the law shouldn't be applied to Kelly's case. Not only did he call the case enigmatic and say there was a question mark surrounding her guilt, he pointed out that the law wasn't intended to apply to people like her, stating, "'Because of the way it was worded, it slammed her back inside for four more years.
确信皇家检控官已经证明了他们的案件，并表达了他对审判进行方式某些方面的疑虑。自从“无尸体，无假释”立法通过以来，惠利法官加入了许多其他人的行列，呼吁修改这项新法律。在凯利的假释被拒绝后，惠利法官告诉《时事》节目，该法律不应适用于凯利的案件。他不仅称该案件令人费解，并说她的罪行存在问号，他还指出该法律并非旨在适用于像她这样的人，并指出：“‘由于措辞的原因，它把她又关了四年。’
I believe that had this law not been passed, then she would be back in the community where she belongs.'" He told the ABC that this law was particularly problematic in cases where the offender maintained their innocence. What is the point of judges making the sentences if the legislation extends the time they spend in prison, Justice Whealy asked. We shouldn't increase the time they spend in jail if they're maintaining their innocence because if they didn't commit the crime, they have no idea of where the body might be. One of Kelly's most vocal supporters, Dr. Zanthi Mallett, told the ABC that the point of the nobody no parole law was to provide closure
“我相信，如果这项法律没有通过，那么她就会回到她所属的社区。”他告诉ABC，这项法律在罪犯坚持自己无罪的情况下尤其成问题。惠利法官问道，如果立法延长了他们在监狱中度过的时间，那么法官做出判决的意义何在？“如果他们坚持自己无罪，我们就不应该增加他们在监狱中度过的时间，因为如果他们没有犯罪，他们根本不知道尸体可能在哪里。”凯利最直言不讳的支持者之一，赞西·马利特博士告诉ABC，“无尸体，无假释”法律的目的是为了提供结案
for victims' families. Dr. Mallett said that didn't apply in Kelly's case because, quote, "...the family of Tegan is also Kelly's family and they believe in her innocence. You have to wonder if we keep Kelly in prison, who is that serving?" Kelly Lane is due to be released in 2028. She continues to maintain her innocence. While Kelly's critics often point out that she has never shown any remorse, her supporters rebut that Kelly didn't kill Teigen so she has nothing to be remorseful about. If Teigen Lane is still alive as Kelly claims, she would be 28 years old at the time this episode goes to air. To this day, no evidence of Teagan's existence beyond the day
给受害者的家人。马利特博士说，这在凯利的案件中并不适用，因为：“……蒂根的家人也是凯利的家人，他们相信她是无罪的。你不得不怀疑，如果我们把凯利关在监狱里，这到底是在为谁服务？”凯利·莱恩定于2028年获释。她继续坚持自己无罪。虽然凯利的批评者经常指出她从未表现出任何悔意，但她的支持者反驳说，凯利没有杀害蒂根，所以她没有什么可后悔的。如果蒂根·莱恩像凯利声称的那样还活着，那么在本集播出时她将是28岁。直到今天，除了蒂根与凯利离开医院的那一天之外，
she left hospital with Kelly has ever surfaced. Over the years, many have discussed the significance of the mother-daughter relationships highlighted by this case. By Kelly keeping her pregnancy secret from her own mother, she severed any potential relationship with Teigen, and the choices she made in that regard then impacted her relationship with her daughter Emily. During her incarceration, Kelly has only been allowed to speak to Emily for 10 minutes a day. When Kelly was sentenced, Justice Whealy remarked, it is a tragedy at three levels. This case reflects the most profound tragedy of the relationship between mother and daughter. Kelly's parents continued to support her. When asked by 60 Minutes if they believed Kelly's story about what happened to Tegan, her mother
没有任何关于蒂根存在的证据浮出水面。多年来，许多人讨论了此案所强调的母女关系的重要性。通过凯利对她自己的母亲隐瞒怀孕，她切断了与蒂根的任何潜在关系，而她在这方面所做的选择随后影响了她与女儿艾米丽的关系。在监禁期间，凯利每天只被允许与艾米丽通话10分钟。当凯利被判刑时，惠利法官评论说，这是一个三个层面的悲剧。这个案件反映了母女关系中最深刻的悲剧。凯利的父母继续支持她。当被《60分钟》问及他们是否相信凯利关于蒂根发生了什么的故事时，她的母亲
Sandra responded, yes I do. It sounds improbable, but a lot of improbable things happen in life." Kelly's father Robert agreed, adding, When 18-year-old Nea May went missing in 2002, her family did everything they could to help the police find her. But, like so many missing persons cases, there comes a time when the leads dry up and there's nowhere left to look. At no point have we just got on with our lives. I heard something recently that really resonated. It was a woman from America who said that
桑德拉回答说：“是的，我相信。这听起来不太可能，但生活中发生了很多不太可能的事情。”凯利的父亲罗伯特表示同意，并补充说：“当18岁的尼娅·梅在2002年失踪时，她的家人尽了一切努力帮助警方找到她。但是，像许多失踪人员案件一样，总有一天线索会枯竭，再也没有地方可找了。我们从来没有仅仅继续我们的生活。我最近听到了一些真正引起共鸣的话。那是一位来自美国的女性，她说
you never get over grief, you learn to move forward with it. And I was like, that's the best anyone's ever described it. Niamh's sister, Fionnuala, realised that a podcast might help find the answers the family was looking for. So for the past four years, I've been working with Niamh's family to take a closer look at the case. And what we found took us to places we never anticipated. Here's everything we've done. We've obviously got serious concerns about her welfare. I've just spoken to the last person to see her alive that we knew about, and he's given me a bullshit story.
你永远无法克服悲伤，你学会了带着它继续前进。我当时想，这是任何人描述得最好的方式。”尼娅的妹妹菲奥努拉意识到，播客可能有助于找到家人正在寻找的答案。因此，在过去的四年里，我一直与尼娅的家人合作，更仔细地审视这个案件。我们发现的东西把我们带到了我们从未预料到的地方。这是我们所做的一切。我们显然对她的福利有严重的担忧。我刚刚和我们所知的最后一个见到她活着的人谈过，他给了我一个胡说八道的故事。
When I first started looking into this case in 2020, it was originally intended to be a single case file episode. But the more I looked, the more I found. So Steve, he's adamant that she never made it to Go Cup Road. Stan, he's adamant that there's a credible sighting there. Nehems set out for a gap year after finishing high school to test her independence, but she never made it home. What happened in those final days? And when the Blackhurst arrived, these two men got out and as soon as I saw them and I saw that black hearse, I thought, their baddies stay away from them.
当我2020年第一次开始调查这个案件时，它最初打算成为《Casefile》的一集。但我看得越多，发现的就越多。所以史蒂夫，他坚信她从未到达过Go Cup Road。斯坦，他坚信那里有一个可信的目击点。尼娅在高中毕业后开始了一年的间隔年，以测试她的独立性，但她从未回家。在最后几天发生了什么？当灵车到达时，这两个男人走了出来，我一看到他们，看到那辆黑色灵车，我就想，他们是坏人，离他们远点。
Mum called me and she said, look, the police are investigating now and somebody claims that they dropped her off and she was hitchhiking. What started out as a potential case fileile episode turned into a 12-part series that took over four years to research. He didn't smile or anything, he just kind of looked empty and just like get in the car. It was just kind of like aggressively like get in the car. Join me as we uncover what happened in Missing Nehiem, the new 12-part podcast series from Casefile Presents. Something had obviously woken me suddenly because I was disorientated.
妈妈给我打电话，她说：“看，警方现在正在调查，有人声称他们把她放下了，她当时正在搭便车。”最初可能成为《Casefile》一集的节目变成了一个12部分的系列，花了四年多的时间进行研究。“他没有笑什么的，他只是看起来很空洞，就像‘上车’。这就像是一种侵略性的‘上车’。”加入我，我们将揭开《寻找尼娅》的真相，这是来自《Casefile Presents》的全新12部分播客系列。显然有什么东西突然把我吵醒了，因为我感到迷失方向。
That's when I realised that there was just a cold, rough hand holding my hand because I had my hand over the edge of the bed and I could see the outline of somebody leaning over the bed. Evil, I guess, has to be somewhat attractive, doesn't it? Otherwise, I wouldn't be able to sneak into every corner. So I whispered to my sister. I asked her if she was awake and she said yes. I said, there's someone in the room, and she said, I know.
就在那时，我意识到有一只冰冷、粗糙的手握着我的手，因为我的手放在床边，我可以看到有人弯腰在床上的轮廓。我想，邪恶必须有一定的吸引力，不是吗？否则，我就无法潜入每一个角落。所以我对我的妹妹耳语。我问她是否醒着，她说是的。我说，房间里有人，她说，我知道。
Missing Nehiem is available now. Be sure to download and follow Missing Nehiem wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《寻找尼娅》现已上线。请务必在您获取播客的任何地方下载并关注《寻找尼娅》。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。